Whoa, okay.
Let me fix the volume.
Hello, testing, testing.
All right, guys.
Oh, wait, there's more audio options.
There's more audio options now.
Oh, wait, there are now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Holy shit.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Why wasn't that on the menu?
That's so crazy.
The menu was like three options, like two options.
The menu was like, do you want audio?
Yes, no.
Do you want audio?
And also, do you want to mute the main menu music?
Like... You could still do that.
The main menu music was really loud.
Yeah.
You could still mute the main menu music.
By the way, for those who don't know, Naima and I are both very sick.
But that doesn't stop us from getting the news.
I'm going away from the sickies.
The news doesn't sleep.
The world doesn't sleep for us.
We're going to get photos of Spider-Man.
Wait,
I can edit?
Oh, shit.
I was going to say let's edit because I can't tell who's...
Oh, no, I can be... I know exactly who I want to be.
We just immediately both went for it.
I know who I... Ladies, ladies, who will get me photos of Spider-Man?
You look like a cop.
No, I look like a cop.
You look like a fucking... Like, those like undercover cops, but they were definitely not undercover.
This one actually looks like, you know, when people are like, look, it's Vi, but with Jinx's hair color.
Oh, yeah.
Where is Snuffy?
Is it like laggy?
Not laggy, but like... It's just unresponsive, which I kind of expected.
Oh, are we conspiracy theorists?
Oh, are we?
Wait, what is this?
I mean...
We're gonna figure out who shot JFK.
Oh, I can hear a vague echo.
That looks like JFK right there.
Do I?
I don't think so.
We're gonna figure out... Oh, I do hear it.
What?
Doki, you're echoing.
Oh, am I echoing?
Okay, let me fix this.
You're just mildly...
I think I know why.
Okay, it should be better now.
Is it good now?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Yeah, that's better.
Thank you.
Oh my god, hey, what's up?
Wait, is that... Oh my god, there's planes and everything.
All right, we need... Okay, wait, let me check this.
I like the YouTube red circle.
Plane.
Do you see it?
Did you see it?
Okay, guys, if we... It looks like I'm lagging in and out because I'm tabbing out and in because I'm trying to find Snuffy.
Snuffy has yet to un-private her stream.
I will... Wait, no, I do... No, she's invisible, right?
I don't even see her.
Oh, so if you, like, run, it does that.
Oh, she's called Snum.
Oh, she's called Snum?
I'll invite her.
I was like, where is she?
Yeah, I don't know.
I typed Snu, and I was like, oh, there she is, and then, like, compulsively hit the F key, and then she went, and I was like, what?
Oh, yeah, no, she's invisible.
I invited her anyway, maybe I'll let her come in.
All right, we'll see.
All right, let me get some cough drops.
It was advised that I should only take one per day.
Did you really name this the Sloppy Sister Session?
Yeah, I did.
Sloppy Station?
We are reporters.
All right, let's see.
I'll just up everybody.
My audio guy was like, does this game have individual volume sliders for people?
No.
Snuffy says the game blue screened her.
Oh, that's a good start to the day.
Hey, guys, join the Discord here.
Say we sent you.
Tell them.
And tell them to sponsor us.
Hey, you blue screened our friend.
Okay, but maybe not.
I think that's, like, a hate rate.
I think that's, like, actually sending a... Oh, I thought you were just telling us, not your chat.
Yeah, no, don't do that.
Don't do that.
Okay, if you do that, say that Lime who sent you.
No, I don't know.
Junior abuses her power.
Zero involvement in this.
Wait, there's a store here.
Oh, shit, I can get score shoes.
We need a pro camera trap.
I want score shoes.
God, why is there always a flashlight and a pro flashlight?
It means the flashlight standard is going to be $40.
Sorry, guys.
I am in a lot of debt for my...
I'm in a lot of debt.
Is this just a higher budget version of that free game that came out after Lethal Company where you went down into this creepy place and recorded things and then watched it back afterwards?
Content warning.
Content warning, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I thought, too.
It looked really, like, it looked a lot like content warning.
It reminds me of that.
I didn't play that.
Darwin Awards.
Miss Darwin.
Returns to flirt with death for a laugh.
I think that's cool.
Yeah, I'm ready to flirt.
Anything.
Oh my god, what the fuck is that?
Those are some of the monsters.
Oh, I think that's why it's weird is the run is not hold shift.
It's like tap.
Is it?
Your run looks really stupid.
Oh, yeah.
Look at the run.
So, okay.
You.
I think.
Wait, what are the other controls?
Oh, there's crouch.
Oh, the crouch is so laggy.
I think, yeah, it's really laggy.
Yeah.
I think it's not.
I think it's toggled, not like.
Yeah, it is.
It's toggle.
Yeah.
Oh, look at it go.
Oh, the press.
I don't.
Oh, wait, wait.
These are equipment.
We only have 10 pictures.
How do you use it?
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Get over here.
Okay.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, next to me.
Next to me.
I'm here.
Oh, next to you.
Oh.
Oh, what's that look like?
It's beautiful.
Oh, you can't.
Hello, everybody.
Microplayer here.
Oh, wow.
That's what I look like?
What is Lama doing?
Hey, Lama.
You look like an actual.
Sorry, I'm giving.
I'm giving snuffy Oh, yeah.
Apparently, she blue screened.
And no, and no, it like crashes every time she boots.
Oh, what?
The game like killed her.
So I'm giving my text.
Out of all the game.
All right, guys, here's some pro tips when taking photos.
Oh, the high, the higher the angle, the more flattering you look, guys, right here.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Oh, yeah.
Don't take pictures like this.
Take pictures like this.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that angle.
So how did you do flash?
Hey, guys, welcome back to my channel.
There's no flash.
I just have a flashlight.
My name is Petey Peter Peterson.
This is a private session.
I thought this was a collab.
Uh, this is a lab party.
What do you mean?
Oh, collab with other YouTubers.
I'm all.
Oh, you're solo.
You're flying solo.
Yeah.
And today we're going to do a crazy challenge.
See if I can get a monster to do 20 squats or every squat it does.
I'll lose ten thousand dollars.
Okay, guys.
Remember to hit that like button.
Yeah, subscribe, subscribe, subscribe.
And get that notification.
Oh, the bell, the bell, the bell.
Ding dong, ding dong.
Go jump around while you're in selfie mode.
How am I holding the camera?
I'm just.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Doki Bird and today we're gonna go see some monsters today.
Oh, I see one right in front of me.
Whoa, me too.
Oh, my God.
Say cheese.
Oh, there she is.
Today, right here is what we call.
Oh, she's outside her natural habitat right now.
Well said, I got this then immediately regrets it.
These are the last known photos of our journalist bathtub people.
Oh, my God, it is.
Oh, my God.
I love this one.
Look at the monster.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wow.
Johnny boy.
Oh, my God.
Got some at the end.
Yeah, that could be the last photo before she before she died.
How did he die here?
How did Captain Peter die?
I don't think he died.
No, these are all like last photos before they died, though.
Oh, I like this guy's photo here.
This one's good.
He looks so like, I'm afraid he's ready.
He's facing death and he's facing it head on with his back.
I think this one is funny, too.
This one like, you know, someone else took that photo right here.
He's like, he's not behind us, right?
Wait, what?
Wow.
Is this like a spoiler of things?
Oh, my gosh, there's a giant lady.
Wait, proceed.
What?
What am I doing?
Get in the camera.
Yeah, buddy.
Yeah, let's go.
Press seven.
Seven?
Let's go.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, it's like, oh, what number was that?
What number did you press?
Six.
Hey there, buddy.
Wait, wait, do it the lime.
Do it the lime.
No, no, no, your other hand is going up.
What's the other one?
Oh, this one?
I think it's this one.
Oh, no, the wrong way.
You got to be on the other side.
Okay.
Like that?
Nope.
I don't know what I'm doing.
He's a perpetual hover hander.
I'm really scared.
Oh, my God.
I'm so close to another woman.
You get points for, like, doing emotes in the picture.
Oh, yeah.
What's number five for me?
It's like pointing, I think.
You.
Yeah, it's pointing.
Okay, download it to desktop folder.
Cool.
She's downloading the photos from the game.
Yeah.
Hello.
What am I doing?
Oh, wait, what am I doing?
Oh, wait.
Like this, like this.
Yeah.
We need a chair.
We need a chair for this.
You're, like, opposite of it.
You're looking at the chair.
You're not sitting in the chair.
Oh, it's like sitting backwards in a chair.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Oh, yeah, that's what I'm trying to do.
It doesn't actually work like that.
What's number two?
You're jiving.
It looks like we're doing the twist.
Yeah, let's do the twist.
Hello, I'm Paul.
Is that your name?
Hi, I'm Paul.
Hey, Paul.
Hey, everybody.
Oh, man.
Shrink resolution real quick and shit.
Oh, is that game still crashing her?
Uh, she's, like, trying to kill the resolution and stuff on it right now.
I'm going to go and investigate and see how it's going for her if she's live.
Okay.
She'll be live if she blue screen.
Yeah, I was gonna say that too.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I like how we already used her camera's battery and we're not even out of the lobby yet.
Oh my god, that's a giant woman.
Should we put it back?
Giant woman.
I know.
I'm excited for that one.
Yeah, I hope she steps on us.
Get that.
Then we're gonna explore the things we're gonna see.
We're gonna race to two dice to her first.
We could go right now.
Nah, we'll wait.
We'll go.
Yeah, we gotta wait for Snuffy.
Snap great pictures then get the F out.
Green doors equals get in.
They put too many stars.
Get the F-U-C-K.
No, F-U-C-K.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's the freak out.
Get the freak out.
Oh, no.
Oh my gosh.
Does your thing start like lagging when you start running?
Like it starts going like... No, it's fine for me.
I think I might have the tankier PC.
Said the person who needed to get replaced.
Yeah, but now it's okay.
It crashed like two days ago, but now it's okay.
Okay.
Oh, we have no money.
We can get a trap.
We can get a big backpack.
Why are we gonna do a helmet?
Are they like, what are you gonna throw rocks at me?
Like rocks at us?
They could.
I mean, it doesn't look too dangerous.
No, it's so clean.
Yeah.
Is that like it's like a there's like shooting stars.
I don't think they're not bullets, right?
No, right?
No, that's not gunfire.
I mean, you're an ambulance.
I mean, to be fair, there is no one walking outside, but it's like, you know, after curfew.
Ever since the government instated a nationwide curfew, you know, this is how it's gonna look like now.
I think it's a nice warm ambiance.
I like it.
It's kind of smoggy.
Yeah, it's just New York City.
Yeah, regular New York City night.
Wasn't like New York City like red at one point because of like the fires?
Yeah, actually.
Yeah, see?
That's actually what I was thinking of.
Oh no, we threw away the newspaper.
We're failures at journalism.
Nobody wants to read our paper.
No, it's because we're starting our career now.
We're gonna make it big.
We're gonna get the front page news, guys.
I'm in a lot of debt because I decided to go into journalism in 2025.
Oh, why does my thing do that when I run?
Why does it do that?
Nothing is still having problems.
I'm trying to help fix it.
What's going on?
It might be, you know, the whole thing where Intel CPUs or we're like getting really unstable.
It might be something like that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not sure.
I'm like, I'm like, yeah, I'm kind of like scanning her chat.
And it's like, oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
I think it might be like degraded CPU thingy.
Oh, she might need to turn it like underclock her PC then.
To play headliners?
That's crazy.
Yeah, headliners too powerful.
Oh, no.
The only time I've ever had to underclock my PC was for Marvel Rivals.
That's crazy.
Marvel Rivals runs so weird.
Like, no matter what I change, it runs at basically the same frame rate.
Yeah, it's just incredibly tanky in general.
Yeah.
Is there batteries?
Oh, there's batteries for flashlight, by the way.
Oh, I put my phone away.
I was like, wait, I wonder if I could take your phone.
I mean, your camera.
Oh, I can.
If I can take your camera, I can take your like, I can see your photos.
Wait, do you see it?
Yeah, yeah.
Head bobbing.
Maybe it's that.
Okay, let me try it.
Oh, there's head bobbing?
Apparently, I think maybe that's what's...
Sorry.
Bless you.
No, there isn't.
Where's the head bobbing part?
I don't see it.
I don't know.
That's what somebody told me.
There's no head bobbing.
Liar.
I got one guide.
You got one guide.
Yeah, maybe.
Glitch or network lag.
That might be it, I think.
Everything else is running fine.
Maybe I should have hosted because I'm the most central.
Yeah, you can host everyone.
That's not why am I hosting?
I'm west coast.
Yeah, we only have time to switch it up while stuffy tries to figure this out.
Yeah, yeah, you host it.
Get out.
Get out of my room right now.
Okay, I'm kicking you out.
Get out.
Bye, everybody.
Thanks for the stream.
This was a lot of fun.
All right, bye, everyone.
That was so fun being in the lobby.
Bye, guys.
Bye, bye.
All right, time to wait for my invite.
We gotta wait for Mint to invite.
Oh my god, my voice.
It's not doing so well, guys.
The worst part is I have a sponsor tomorrow.
Yesterday, I was like, I'm all right.
But it should be fine.
Today, I am.
I'm sucking on a cough drop right now.
Today, I'm like, I woke up and I was like, what happened?
I'm drinking tea right now.
Yeah, I'm drinking tea at the moment.
The counteract, everything.
Literally, I woke up.
I couldn't even like get words out of my mouth.
So this is like a huge improvement right now.
Because before then, I couldn't even say a single word.
And then I literally was like, I woke up, made tea, got Manuka honey, and then got the Chinese herbal medicine.
You guys know which one?
The black one.
And then I was just... And also, I did the Buckley's cough syrup because I needed something to soothe the throat.
So I was just like, okay, all of those.
And then I took a shower too with the steam.
So I literally was just like, every medication possible.
Right now.
I'm maxing everything.
So yeah, and then I also got tea as well.
So I joined the game.
I should be able to join.
Hello, I'm here.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Oh, you have like three lives too.
What is?
I have three what?
You have three lives.
That's like the little passes, right?
Yeah, I think that's what the passes are.
Yeah.
Or press pass.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is already looking so much better.
Oh, it must have been the ping then.
I'm fine though.
On your server.
Okay.
I don't know what it was.
Maybe it was like, also with Limu connecting.
Maybe.
I don't know, actually.
Because like for me, because then she wouldn't cheat.
Apparently, VTube studio.
What the fuck?
Well, what happened?
Press.
I feel like the press badge is showing up.
Okay, they're gone.
I think those are lives.
Like it shows you how much lives you have.
So apparently it was VTube studio.
Oh, it was VTube studios.
I think it's like her CPU is dying so hard that having both running kind of broke everything.
Oh, so today was the day she found out her PC's dying.
I think they already did the thing where they under vaulted it.
It's just not anymore or something.
Um, no, if you under vaulted, if you under clock your PC too much, you start breaking your PC.
Yeah.
So like, I think she just needs to get a new PC at this point.
Because she, I mean, the 50, the 50x series comes out.
That means the PC's died.
Rest in peace.
You hear me saying, my, my, snuffy's PC died.
Tried to play headliners and she got a new PC.
And her CP, no, her PC died.
Tried to play headliners and her CPU fried.
Hell yeah.
Wait,
uh, Limo, do you want to change back to your old outfit?
Oh, right, right, right.
Hold on a second.
She'll be the token woman in the group.
Hell yeah.
Actually, oh, I'm going to be this guy.
You're bald.
That's it?
He's like, mm-hmm.
Yeah, so what?
I don't look like I belong in New York.
Like, I look like Seinfeld.
You look like, well, the one thing that's missing is that Seinfeld has a head of hair.
No, his friend.
Oh, the other guy.
George.
He doesn't have glasses.
I've never watched Seinfeld, by the way.
I don't know who George is.
I just know Seinfeld.
I've watched all of Seinfeld.
Damn, what a hag.
Like, two years ago.
Sure, sure, two years ago.
Is it because you watched the Seinfeld AI shit?
Is that why you watched Seinfeld?
No, I watched Seinfeld before the AI.
And then I watched the AI and was like, whoa, this is so accurate.
Nothing's happening.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, two years ago.
Yeah, yeah.
I guess that's what they say.
What's the deal with Snuffy's computer?
I think, I think we've gotten there.
She switched models to a less intensive one on and it might not be all right.
I feel so bad for her.
Yeah, it's so frustrating when your computer's not working the way it should.
Yeah, I can't believe- Death by Headliners, what a way to go.
Death by Kuso Games.
Of all the things that take you out, right?
Of all the things, it has to be a Kuso game.
Oh my god, you found a music player, holy shit.
That's right.
Wait, how do you dance again?
It's two.
I actually have this whole thing with Path of Exile 2, where that thing will, like, break my computer, and that sucks.
Nice dancing.
What is your mouth doing when you dance?
Holy shit, what's your mouth doing?
I keep dancing.
Okay, look at the photo, look at the photo.
I'm looking.
You look like you're creeping on her.
Look at him go, look at him go.
No!
Hold on, here you go.
Lime, lime, look at it.
Yeah, I do.
I do a gallery.
Oh man, freaky mirror.
There you go.
Man, what a freak.
That's what they call me at the club.
At the club, let's go.
Whoa, whose scarf is that?
Wait, I wonder if there's new photos.
I'm gonna check.
Oh yeah, see if they've changed.
No, it's the same ones.
Maybe it's just, like, a standard set then.
Yeah, maybe, or, like, yeah, maybe it's, like, submitted, like, uh, Twitter users submit it, and then they change it every so often.
Yeah, we gotta get on here.
We gotta get on here.
All right, we gotta get some good photos then.
Yeah, and if we post these, you guys gotta like it so that they know.
Yeah, yeah, so the devs will add us into the photos.
Yeah.
I wonder if you can change the channels.
Oh, there was a different one earlier.
Maybe...
Oh, see?
Stop laughing at me!
Girls just wanna have fun.
It's almost... It really is.
Walmart girls just wanna have fun.
Oh, there's stuff for Sophia's crush!
No!
In the middle of the night, my mayor of the town said, I'm fighting for my life.
I need someone to take a picture of the kaiju.
The press just wanna have fun.
All the press just wanna have fun.
Apparently, taking my invite to this session caused OBS to crash.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, what's wrong?
What's so fucking... What's wrong?
It's the whole thing that's so cursed for her.
This is so cursed.
Hey, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Which one is it?
Which one?
No, goddammit, which number was it?
It's one, it's one, it's one.
Oh, it's one?
Okay.
Is it working?
No.
Wait, hold on, let me see this.
Does it... Wait, which one is it?
Which one is the hover hand?
Oh, it's six, I think.
Yeah, yeah, six, six.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Does it look like I'm cool against the wall?
It does, actually.
I think that's what it's supposed to be rather than putting your arm around it.
Oh, Snob's here!
Wait, wait, wait, oh my god, welcome!
Snuffy!
Hello?
Hi, you're here!
You're with us!
Oh my god, it's using the good... Okay, wait, hold on, I...
Look at this.
Hello.
We missed you.
Wait, what?
I feel... This is wrong.
What did you have to do to get it working?
What did you do?
Naked, I'm completely naked.
I'm like a flesh streamer.
I'm nothing, it's just a game.
I know you're not a model!
You don't have a skin suit on or anything!
Where's my beautiful face and like, quirky traits?
Just add a PNG.
You can like, put your own foogie on the reactive thing on the bottom so you can put yourself there.
You have a PNG to it.
I'm too afraid, anything else...
If you tab out, it'll probably break everything.
It's like Jenga, if I move one thing, it's gonna shatter.
You know what's gonna happen?
We're all gonna be like, super excited, it's gonna finally be working.
We go into the mission and you instantly crash.
I'm gonna do that.
No, you're gonna jinx it!
You're gonna jinx it!
Look at us dance!
We're so happy.
We figured out how to dance, and then we found a copy of Girls Just Wanna Have Fun at Home.
So we're having a really good time.
So there's emotes, you know, number keys are emotes, by the way.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Let me get my foogie up really quick.
Also, there's a girl with blue hair that you can be if you want, over here.
Oh, I thought you guys just made your characters.
No, no, no.
You can choose from the...
You think I would've made this?
Yes, 100%.
So that was my first pick, was that was instantly, you made that.
Oh, thank you!
Wait, wait, wait, lean against the wall so I can take that picture.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It should be the brick wall, the brick wall.
That's where the aesthetic is.
Check me out, check me out.
I'm like, wistfully looking out the window.
Tonight, we're gonna be catching some real monsters.
Don't talk, don't talk when you do it.
Look at it.
Look at your expression.
He's just a chill guy.
Just a chill guy.
The smile.
Look at this photo.
That took a minute.
It looks too...
It looks too chill.
Oh, I gotta drop my camera.
Oh, wait, no, that's my flash.
I'll drop everything, whatever.
What you got in there?
Nothing.
Okay.
Oh, there you go.
My camera has all the real photos.
It has all the real photos.
Oh, yeah, I like that one.
Okay, I think I'm good now.
What did we learn?
We've learned...
We learned about the emotes.
The most important part.
I think that's the best one we got.
I'm just basically like, screw the rules.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, for the photos.
Alright, you guys all ready?
Oh, yeah, Stephanie, go get your camera.
Oh, okay.
Did you ever play content warning, Snuffy?
I feel like this is just modern...
Or, you know...
This setting is...
Yeah, modern.
Or, no, no, Cloverfield content warning.
That's what it is.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This really looks like Cloverfield.
It's a movie where, like, a big old...
Godzilla type thing...
This is basically Cloverfield.
Right there.
Wait, this guy.
Okay, no, the monster.
The monster is Cloverfield.
It had, like, crazy ARG marketing when it first came out.
What was the name of the drink that was, like, responsible?
Like, there was a drinks company and they were drilling for the secret ingredient for the drink.
What?
The Cloverfield had a drink.
I swear to God, hold on.
Slusho.
Slusho, yeah, Slusho drinks.
Chat, we are in the natural habitat of hags right now as they...
As we discussed...
As they reminisced...
About the ARG...
The Slusho ARG.
I was just like, the ARG of Slusho.
You guys were alive when that...
You guys understood...
You guys were alive when...
When the ARG Cloverfield came out.
I'm gonna shine a fucking flashlight in your face the whole time.
I swear to God.
Arthur Square.
Danger level one.
Is she still with us?
There are only three people in here.
Where did she go?
We already lost someone.
We already lost.
Did she fall off the helicopter?
Hello?
Oh, no!
I'm sorry.
I can hear you.
That sucks.
I knew it would happen.
I was like, is Snoopy still here?
And then there were only three people in the helicopter.
No!
Snoopy!
Yeah, like, who would've thought?
This game looks so, like, casual.
It does.
It's cause you're a raccoon.
Wait, it shows you're still in the game, though.
Yeah, maybe if you reloaded, you'll be in here.
Yeah, it shows current session, your name, and...
Snum!
I see you, Snum!
No, Snum!
Where are you, Snum?
I don't mean to weird you out, but there's a guy that keeps running by in his underwear.
I think maybe if you invite her back in, maybe it'll, like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see if it'll crash your OBS again.
I just see...
I just see Snum!
Oh, I see Snum there.
Guys...
Guys, there's...
There's people crying outside, guys.
It's alright!
Yeah, it's all good!
Your head keeps twisting!
Yeah, you keep doing this!
Bye, Posty!
Bye-bye!
Bye!
I'm so sad.
Guys, okay, now that...
Why on earth can we 360 our heads?
That's fucking...
I don't know.
We don't have a time limit, we have six minutes left.
We have six minutes to capture footage, yeah.
Yeah, so...
Guys, there was a lot of sounds around me, I'm really scared.
There was a guy in his underwear that ran past us at the very start.
I didn't want to disrupt the heartfelt conversation with Snuffy, but he fucking sprinted past us in his undies.
I was like, alright.
Maybe that was the monster.
The monster was inside us.
Oh, there he is!
Wait, that's a normal guy.
Oh, he's a survivor.
Hello, survivor.
You have a witness account?
She's not interested in your shit.
Hello, can you give us a statement?
Can you give us a statement, real quick?
We just want to know, what did you see over there?
What did you see?
What did you see, sir?
One sentence from you.
Oh, goodbye.
Wait, there's a monster?
Oh shit, let's go!
Wait, pose in front of him!
Pose in front of him!
Here, I'll pose in front.
Where is he?
Right in front of you.
Alright, I got a photo.
Nice.
The dog alien.
Are you alive?
Holy shit, let me out!
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Take a picture of this.
I'm next to the...
Dude, she's in fucking pieces on the floor.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm going to wait until he finishes eating.
Alright, take a picture of this.
Alright, I got like enough for maybe one more picture.
This camera sucks.
Alright, we got the photo.
Right there.
We got Mint's like horrible scattered corpse parts.
What more could we need?
Wait, I can use her body parts as weapons.
She got like absolutely murdered.
Okay, I'm going to grab a body part real quick.
Oh, there's a dude in his underwear!
Behind you!
Okay, we need to get her camera because she had photos too.
Oh shit!
Oh!
Whoops.
I threw that.
It's alright.
I got the real deal.
The guy with his underwear is just running around by the cars now.
Wait, wait, we need to take a picture of that.
We need to take a picture of that.
He's below us.
Look, I'm bringing Mint over.
That's right, move away.
I've covered wars, you know.
Wait, where's the underwear guy?
Wait, did Mint do that?
Hey, I tried to tell you!
Okay, how do we get out of here?
We just go back to the plane?
I think we just go back to the helicopter, yeah.
You know what, I feel like we did a good job.
Yeah, I got some cool pictures.
Yeah, look, and she's like here with us.
It's like she never died.
Do you think we get a reward for bringing back her torso?
I think so, let's try.
Okay.
Everyone's here.
Don't worry Mint, we're going to piece you back together and make Robocop.
We'll fix you right up.
I'm a journalist, you know.
Oh yeah, battle, thank you for the raid battle.
Alright, look, we did it!
We fixed her!
Oh look, yeah, no, you're doing great.
I told you!
We made it, we can rebuild her.
We're checking the results on the TV.
Check the results.
Alright, alright.
Do I have to like, plug in?
Results.
Oh, here we go.
Um...
Yeah, that's me!
Wait, why is it just me?
I got every good photo.
Yeah!
Where am I?
What do you mean, there you are.
I literally see you, you're right here.
Very good.
Good job, everybody.
Did we just take like, the top photo, I guess?
From everything, which would be this one.
Yeah, that's the top photo, because I got the dog alien, and then you dying, and then blood.
Oh, so we can buy like, more stuff now, like a pro camera, so we can take more photos.
I'm yelling at this for a while, it's like, ma'am, ma'am, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
And there's me dancing next to your body part.
Oh, we need to convert the points into photos, I'm sorry, into money, which I guess we can only do at the end.
Yeah, we just need...
Okay, so we have two more press badges, so we can do this two more times to get past the first level.
Yeah, got you, got you.
So we need to reach 1500 by the... Okay, got you, got you.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Min, why didn't you emote next to the...
Min, why didn't you emote next to the dog?
Like, we could've gotten more points.
Yeah, why didn't you fucking dab, dude?
Yeah, why didn't you dab?
Sorry, he came at me and then...
What university did you graduate to?
I don't even think you have a degree in journalism.
Well, then he attacked me again, so he can get you twice, I think.
Oh, wait, how do we get the plane to start?
I think it won't because Snuffy is still technically in the...
Oh, no, she's gone.
Oh, okay.
Hey, Mr. Dude.
Oh, oh, I need to equip a camera to...
Oh, you'll have a camera.
It's you.
Wait, there's no cameras here.
Oh.
Oh, no, no, you have to buy a camera.
I don't have any money.
No, it's your dollars.
The shit camera is free.
I don't get my flashlight back, though.
Thanks for grabbing that instead of, you know...
I rebuilt you.
Oh, that's the thanks I get after rebuilding you?
Alright, I see.
I literally rebuilt you from nothing.
From just a torso.
Okay, let's go.
Alright.
We're off to see everything in the city.
Danger level one?
Oh, my gosh.
You died on the danger level one.
Yeah, you did.
Who told you to?
Yeah, man, lock in.
To be fair, she is a ghost, so she's pretty good at dying.
I don't know.
All those photos were of me, mostly, though.
Is he still there?
Alright, then we're free to go down.
Hello?
Oh, we can go in!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Let's go in.
I mean, it's threat level one.
What is that?
Oh, did you hear someone giggling?
It's just a phone booth.
Run away!
Oh, it's a very spooky phone booth.
Oh,
I'm opening, too.
Goodbye!
Oh, I have to hold it.
Oh, hello!
Oh, I'm going to take a photo right now.
Oh, I have a simple photo.
Oh, what if I do a selfie?
Guys, guys, guys, get over here!
Guys, guys, guys, come on!
What's up?
Selfie time!
What?
What was that?
No?
Are you okay?
Mint?
Are you sure?
Alright, let's go in, then.
I'm in.
Are you getting PTSD from your OL days?
What's with the mist above us?
Do you see that?
The ghostly essence?
Yeah.
What the hell was that?
It was called a stalker, so I think maybe we don't want to get stalked.
Are you hiding?
Wait, can we all be in here?
No, but we can kick each other out.
Someone is going to get fucking eaten.
Oh, okay, we're good.
We can move.
I have a feeling a stalker isn't coming.
I feel like he's going to come back.
I'm fine in here.
Be brave!
I saw...
I got a picture.
Hold on, I'm going to emote on him.
Is he coming back?
He's not here.
We gotta get out.
I got out.
We're right here.
What the fuck?
He's a hiding survivor.
He's hiding, so he clearly knows what's going on.
What are you doing?
Can you fucking move?
Do you have anything you want to tell us?
Any statement you want to make?
I'm actually stuck.
Who is this?
He's a hiding survivor.
He's here to hide.
Every time I talk in game discord, I can see on my second monitor.
It's like, you're currently muted.
Look at him.
There's like a trap here.
Oh shit.
It's a constant warning trap.
You don't have good photos, right?
Is this guy actually following us?
He's probably shit scared.
We should trick him into the trap so we can take a picture of him getting eaten.
True, true, true.
We're awful people.
No, we're not.
We're journalists.
Maybe move onto the other side of the trap so he can follow us.
He's kind of fixated.
I think he's fixated on you.
Hey kid, come on.
Let's go somewhere safe.
Over here.
Here he comes.
Get your cameras ready.
Come on.
It's going all technical outside.
That's probably bad.
Is it?
It kind of went all purple out there.
It's just rain.
It's just acid rain.
Oh no, it's the lighting system in here.
Okay, we're fine.
I feel like we should go back.
We have a lot of good photos now, right?
Oh, I see it.
What was it?
It's in the other room.
I saw red eyes running around.
It's a soccer.
Wait, how did we get back?
I don't remember where we came from.
This way.
Up the stairs.
We're actually leaving?
Did we really come from up the stairs?
No, it's not up the stairs.
I don't think so.
It was through here.
Oh, I can't see anything.
Wait, I don't have a...
You're here.
I got you.
It was here because there's a locker.
And that's where I took a photo of you.
Yeah, and it's straight through here.
Yeah, I think we should go back.
I think we have all the photos we need, right?
Six photos I can take.
I'm about halfway through mine.
So it depends on whether or not we want to risk dying.
Yeah, I don't want to risk dying.
We have some sick ass photos for the news.
There might be some shit in the square as well.
We're gonna get eaten.
Ladies first.
Alright.
Everything seems safe.
There's no dogs here.
Oh, there's two dogs.
Is that a not dog?
That's three enemies right there.
Can you zoom?
Look at them go.
Oh, fleeing survivor dead.
Is this like Lethal Company where the longer you're out, the more...
I don't think so.
I think it's just RNG.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh god, can you actually make that?
Parkour.
I can't get up there.
Guys, don't come over here.
You'll get stuck, JK.
Parkour.
Oh wait, apparently the longer we're out here, the more likely monsters spawn.
You're right.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Hurry.
The longer we're out here, the more monsters there are.
Alright, let's go, let's go, let's go.
There's a monster below us.
To our right.
So we gotta book it, we gotta book it.
He's like right to the right.
Okay, where?
What do you mean where?
We're gonna go.
Alright, three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go.
I'm booking, I'm running as fast as I can.
Guys?
Guys, there is a monster right in front of me.
Oh my god, he's right there.
Turn around, turn around, take a photo, take a photo of him.
Nice.
I can just hear you in the distance like, guys?
I can't believe you fuckers left me.
I can't, I'll...
Doki bird will remember this.
I got a great photo while you were running.
Alright, who's gonna have the top photos?
What is that?
You streaked in front of me as I was taking a photo.
It was really funny.
Number four.
Number three.
Yes, my photo.
What is that?
Oh, that's...
That's right, that's right.
It was me yet again.
It was my photo again.
Wait, you didn't even get a single photo in top five.
We can afford exactly one thing.
What is it?
Do you want a pro camera?
Or do you want, maybe...
A helmet?
What is a helmet for?
I guess a helmet is for more...
I guess we could give a helmet to Mint and then use her as bait more.
Hold on.
It's plus 25% health.
Then...
The trap will block monsters.
We could buy Mint a flashlight.
She doesn't need one.
We have two flashlights.
That's more than enough.
Okay.
There's a zoom camera too for Doki.
Because she doesn't like to get close to anything.
True, but there's also a camera that lets you take 15 pictures.
I got the best photo in that game.
And I was very close to you guys.
Do you want the 15 pictures camera?
Or the zoom camera?
Or the flash camera?
I feel like the zoom camera would be better, right?
You get less score for it.
The flashy camera might be good.
Because we don't have to rely on the flashlight.
True, true.
The pro camera has the best pictures.
For what it's worth.
So you get more score.
So we should get the pro camera then.
I think they have the pro camera then.
So that we can get more money.
Yeah, I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Mine.
Do you want the pro camera?
No, you can have it.
You're gonna get the best shot of all of us now.
Yeah, that's the plan.
Your guy is so close to me right now.
He's like, do you want the pro camera?
While basically licking my nose.
Do you want the pro camera?
I really like your eyeliner.
I can see every one of your pores.
It goes around your whole eyes.
Wow.
I haven't had the use of both of my nostrils.
Since like, I don't know.
Friday.
No.
So you're like.
The color of your hair for real.
Yeah.
What were you?
We're not the sloppy sisters today.
You guys were the snotty sisters.
It's true.
Alright, I'm back.
Did you wash your hands?
Yeah, I did.
Alright, where's the pro camera?
Who has it?
Mint has it because Mint has clearly got a great track record for taking good pictures.
Damn it.
Let's see again.
Let's see.
Which photo did you get in the top five?
This is the front line news?
I'm sorry, this is the front news?
What is this?
And who's with that photo?
It looks like you're in a compromising picture with that fucking monster, if I'm gonna be honest.
Breaking news, I've uncovered a secret relationship.
She really was the freak phantom.
Oh wait, the monster is in that picture.
Yeah, she's literally right there next to you.
She's like right there.
Wow.
That's right, I have a scandal right there.
Extra, extra, read all about it.
Mint got caught with her pants down.
It's not a scandal if I welcome it.
Oh yeah, I had relations with that monster.
I had relations.
Let's go.
Do you think we'll get the scarier map now?
Mint's gonna die with the pro camera.
Oh yeah, probably.
We have a higher thing now too.
All we have in the world is $100.
Mint's definitely not gonna die with the pro camera.
She's gonna die with the pro camera.
I didn't know if that would come through on the loading screen.
Oh, this is a new one.
Yeah, because we finished the last one.
Don't die.
Who are you saying that to?
Mint or me?
This is Adelaide.
That's true.
Oh.
Oh, we might be able to get a panorama shot.
My eyes are up here.
Ladder, ladder, ladder.
You gotta say ladder, ladder, ladder when you climb.
It's the rule.
Oh, do we have to parkour here?
Oh god.
I'm gonna do it.
Parkour!
Okay, watch this.
Parkour.
Very good.
We're the best journalists ever?
Yeah.
Oh, there's a ladder over here too.
Oh, there's a light.
There's a green light.
There's doors below us.
Alright, let's go down.
Jump.
Yeah, do a flip.
Do a flip, Mint.
How do you safely use these fucking ladders?
There's fall damage.
I'm kind of stuck on the ladder.
Okay, here we go.
This is very dangerous.
Holy shit.
Look, as a journalist, you have to take risks, guys.
You have to take risks as a journalist, guys.
Who would take risks if not me?
I was doing it for the people.
Look, we found out that gravity works in this world.
That elevator is smoking.
Oh my god, let me take my Buckley's while we wait.
Let me take my fucking meds while we wait.
Wait, what?
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Wow!
That's fucking gross, though.
Do you want me to pose for it?
I can hear a monster.
Me too.
Wow!
Extra, extra, read all about it.
Guy gets slowly absorbed by the law.
Journalist quoted saying, wow!
Place is pretty spooky.
A little.
I like the echoing.
I know me too.
You're good.
You saw her torso outside.
I know she's watching right now.
I can hear her.
Taking my shtick, man.
No, there's nothing in here.
I guess we can check the security cameras.
Hold on.
Do you hear it?
Where's your camera?
You're alive, you have no leg.
Let's go, let's go.
You are missing a leg.
You are so fucking dead.
The rest of you is dead.
The pro camera!
Wait, can you hear me, man?
It was me that slapped the table.
I slapped the table and you're like...
No, I unmuted Discord and slapped the table.
I made a loud thump noise.
You thought it was the game, but it was me.
It was me.
Look at that, Mitt.
You died with the pro camera.
I had to test the theory out.
Nobody was willing to take the risk but me.
What cause?
I'm gonna die going down the ladder.
If that number one photo is my fucking discombobulated body, you're welcome.
It's gonna be my little alien photo.
Oh my god, what if she like misses the jump?
She's got a lot of time, but I guess because we're all dead...
If I wasn't dead, we would have been able to win this.
Oh.
Yeah, I see it.
You see that thing crawling?
In front of us?
You see that in front of her?
It's literally in front of her.
Lava, turn around!
Your life is not as important as the news.
No problem.
Yeah, she got the pro camera.
The camera that matters.
Okay,
let's see if it counts as your photo.
Top photo.
Oh boy.
It's me!
That's you before you died.
Here you go, Min.
You put a lot of effort.
You sacrificed your life for that shit.
That's a good one.
He's like raising the roof.
That thing was smart.
Did you see?
I tried to lead him around the thing and he immediately kind of figured it out and moved back.
Oh, that's crazy.
Scared as that was.
Level 2.
Yeah, level 2?
I want to know where the big monster is.
You saw the big monster photos?
Yeah.
He was resistant though.
That was scary.
Okay, now that I know how hard it is to take photos...
These photos are actually really, really good.
I know, right?
Oh my god.
This one is so epic.
The one in front of the crotch.
These are really good.
Yeah, these are actually really good.
This one looks like he's running away.
While things are being flipped towards him.
Yeah, the selfie ones are really hard.
Wait, someone said you should be able to pick up all dropped cameras.
Oh, really?
Okay, I threw mine for you.
But I didn't know if I could actually not.
Maybe we should send this photo to the devs.
And be like a scandal.
Yeah, that's not too bad.
Between a journalist and an alien.
You're obsessed with this photo.
I mean, it's a pretty...
Not being jealous of my love life, huh?
It's a pretty good photo, not gonna lie.
Are you guys ready?
On my way.
I'm ready!
Apparently, the big monsters appear in the last minute.
So we stay in the last minute.
We could get a big monster.
Alright.
So for this one...
For this one, we just stay until the last minute then.
Yeah.
If we chill by the helicopter, we should be good.
Live life on the edge.
Oh, you hear that?
I hear something going...
I didn't hear it.
Oh, I see a green light.
Have we been there before?
That green light?
We got a different way because we didn't go up onto the roof immediately.
Oh, true.
Wait, no, this is the same way to the same place.
We never went forward though.
Have we ever went forward?
We could go this way and go into that main building.
We didn't go there last time.
Oh, yeah, let's try that.
What could go wrong?
Exactly, guys.
Hey, look, Doki, on the right there is where you turned into a pancake.
Oh, that's me!
That's where I was!
Oh, look, there's a whole different section over there that we could go up eventually.
That's cool.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we go to the side, right?
Right here?
Oh, no, we went in that one last time.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, well, you guys went there last time.
I was dead.
Oh, no, it's the same building.
Two doors, same building.
That's weird.
Oh, wait, no, the benches are different.
We could go through the elevator.
Oh, there's some monster bloody stuff in here.
Oh, Goopy.
Follow me.
Wait, pose next to her.
Emo, what were you?
Emo.
There's something in here.
Something just opened the door.
Hello?
Oh, I saw it.
A little thing just ran by.
Hello?
Yeah, I think it's the guy that bit off...
Wait, what?
What?
A little baby?
Can we kick the baby?
Alright, let's go.
I ain't scared of a little baby.
I couldn't possibly imagine why.
You should definitely go find out.
Guys, where's the little baby, guys?
Oh, I see what you did there.
Little baby.
She didn't notice.
No, she didn't.
She lacks critical information.
I'm not a baby.
What's this?
What is that?
Is it a breaker box?
Doesn't do nothing.
Is this going to be one of those games, like Lethal Company, where if you find a monster, you're basically just dead?
I don't know.
I think that's what the traps are for.
Alright, guys, do a pose.
I'm not letting you get the best photo.
You do a pose.
Okay, fine.
Wait, wait, wait.
Does it look like I'm cool next to it?
Look.
Against the wall.
Wait, do it again, do it again.
I'm trying not to waste my stamina.
I'm like, trying to keep the doors closed behind us so that we hear if something's coming up behind us.
You're so smart.
That's why she lived and we died.
I know.
I mean, that's exactly why I'm not smart enough.
This room is huge.
There's more annihilation stuff over there.
I thought it looked like annihilation.
It's your life.
It's a movie where you go into this world and then you get absorbed into it.
It's about a prism that instead of refracting light, it refracts.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You look like you're kind of pissing on it.
I'm not going to lie.
Does that work?
What was that?
It's the radio.
It's a radio broadcast.
That's freaky.
We're at the news station.
Yeah.
We should see if there's a way out of this building but not having to go all the way back.
That's going to take forever.
It's a little spooky, not going to lie.
It is a little spooky.
What happens if you stand on it?
Probably nothing good.
Alright guys, are we ready?
Alright.
Are you doing that again?
Wait, we can be the news now.
Oh my god, you're right.
My fellow Americans.
What?
Where did it go?
I got a photo!
I got a cool photo though.
And you kept your leg.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's so cool.
Wait, where did that photo go?
Wait, that's not good.
The baby's back.
Where's the baby?
I don't know, but I can hear him.
New York is under attack.
We should probably get away.
I think so too.
Standing here is a good idea.
No, it's probably not.
Alright, let's get out of here.
I'm watching your back.
Thanks very much.
Oh, I'm so fucking dead.
It's so dark.
We can use the camera for night vision.
There's goop on the floor.
That's a trap, isn't it?
It could be.
We don't have a survivor though to test it.
I mean, we have three survivors right here.
Excuse me, I'm a journalist.
Oh wait, this is a dead end.
Lethal company-ass looking fucking corridor.
I know!
Wait, this is also a dead end.
Yeah, this place sucks.
We could try and book it out the way we came.
What about the left side?
Oh, there's a bed over here.
I mean, these doors are open.
Fucking corridors.
Oh, what's this?
Oh wait, guys!
Oh yeah, we found it!
We did it!
We're heroes!
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Mint.
When I leave a room, I spawn inside someone's fucking head.
I feel like we have to be on the roof at this point.
I see your eyeballs.
Oh my god, there's a survivor.
That's a man with a gun.
That's a man with a bazooka.
He's here!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, military men!
Wait, let me pause.
It's Godzilla!
Hello!
Look over there!
Oh my god, he's right there!
We should run.
Run, run, run.
Guys, I didn't put a photo.
Oh my god, there he is!
All I'm saying is that I did it for the photo.
I like how the helicopter pilot is totally fine.
They can rebuild me.
For the vibe.
I did it for the vibe!
I am a real journalist.
You guys don't care.
You guys don't care enough.
Okay, okay.
I have a pro camera.
Girl, I'm like...
I got so many downward photos from you.
If I am in that photo for a top result, you're welcome.
Oh, look at him.
He's so cute.
Wow!
Oh yeah, Miss Pro Camera.
Where's my photo?
I like how the picture of the ass got more views.
It's me!
Hell yeah!
What did we get?
Oh, we made it to the next level!
Nice!
Should we even like...
wait for the small guys?
All the pictures of the big guys...
I feel like we should just win the Darwin Award.
Just sit in the helicopter until they show up.
Someone else can use the pro camera if you want.
We can actually buy another one if you want to.
Let's get two pro cameras.
I can get a pro flashlight instead.
Oh yeah, maybe.
I will get a pro flashlight this time then.
Is this the pro camera?
That's me, guys.
Look.
There I am, next to the dinosaur.
Do we need another flashlight?
We can take another flashlight.
No, I don't think you're in this one.
No, I'm not in the one that won, but I was second place.
There you go.
Pro flashlight obtained.
I was in this one.
I got it.
That's me.
Oh yeah, that's you.
I'm like, yeah, ADS got the picture.
There's two flashlights there, so we can all have one.
Doki, did you get a flashlight?
Yeah, I got it.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go get some big guys.
Let's get some good photos.
Alright, so we just gotta live until one minute or something.
Or two minutes?
You showed up in the two minute mark.
It wasn't one minute.
Oh, we're in Chinatown.
The more photos we get though, the better we do, so it's still worth getting the others because we got 5,000 points.
I feel like the big monsters show up like here, so we can't be in this area.
Yeah, well probably if we just stand here waiting for the monster, it will just obliterate us.
Yeah, I feel like that's what's gonna happen.
That's true.
Cool.
Spooky.
I like the lanterns.
I can like peek in through other people's windows.
I'm like a little peeping tom.
Don't take photos in there.
What are you guys doing in there?
Picture!
Someone changing!
I bet you when the monster shows up, you could use this ladder to get a really good high aerial shot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get a pose in front of it.
That's how they get the poses, like staring at the monster.
Like a movie poster.
Oh, there's a panorama.
Oh, it's a mall!
I wanna go to the mall.
Let's all go to the mall tonight.
Alright, let's go.
I'll provide flashlight services first, so you guys don't waste yours.
Okay, are you sure?
Wait, what's this?
You can do flashlight.
What is that?
I think those are just lights glowing in the dark.
Did you hear that?
Oh, there's a big thing above us on the left part there.
I hear him.
Where do we go, lad?
You're like the senior reporter.
The one with the biggest flashlight.
You guys not hear him?
I think he's behind us.
Is he?
No?
I think we're hearing our own footsteps.
No, no, no, no.
I'm hearing growls right now.
I'm hearing growls.
I think he's underneath us.
Under where?
Hello?
Monster?
She is a monster.
This photo is old.
Pineapple?
He's sucking on his fingers.
The text is just literally pineapple?
There's nothing in there.
That is a dead end.
Is it procedurally generated?
There's lots of stupid dead ends.
I think that's it.
I mean, that's her replayability.
What is that?
Yeah, I saw that.
I couldn't even see the photo.
I was like, what?
And then it disappeared.
There's something in that room over there too.
Something just went past the camera.
Oh, I hear him.
That's fucking loud.
No, I didn't get a picture.
There's a door here if you want to go in.
Hello?
Oh, there's a little baby thing as well.
It's like a rat.
I saw a rat.
How do you see all these babies?
I've never seen the babies.
You don't want to go in the place where the rat is?
We're going this way?
Alright.
I'm just following you.
There was another place though where there was a little baby rat thing.
I think this leads there.
I think this is the same place.
Oh, there's a survivor.
No, he's just...
He's just doing a little spin.
Don't worry, follow us.
We won't take you to die.
I think this just goes around in a circle.
Maybe?
Pizza?
There's another door here.
Oh, he is following us.
What an idiot.
Break room!
Oh, what's going on in here?
Nevermind.
This goes back around to the start.
Yeah, we're at the start again.
This is where the monster was earlier.
Can you fucking...
Oh, he's right here!
If you want to open it...
Here, I'll pose.
Isn't that the creature that took your leg out?
Oh, there's the spinny Cthulhu!
I got it!
Did you get the photo?
Yeah, I got it.
It looks like a D&D beholder.
He's really right there.
Okay, we open the door.
I take the photo and then we close the door.
Okay.
I'll put the light on it.
Here, tell me...
Oh, open the door.
She's got the pro camera.
3, 2, 1...
Close the door!
For the love of God.
I can't...
Okay.
Where is he?
I don't know where he went.
Yeah, just shut the door.
We should get the fuck out.
Oh my God!
I'm good.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about him.
It's okay.
Are we leaving?
I can't get out!
I'm so sad!
What?
I'm
a little fucked.
Hey there.
It's just you and I.
What do we do?
I'm a little stuck right now.
Okay, I can get out of here.
I can make it!
Take a photo!
I ran out of photos!
I'm okay.
Is she okay?
Parkour!
Wait, where do I go?
I'm heading over!
Oh my God, I'm...
I'm almost there!
I'm here.
Wait, where's everybody else?
Wait, did everybody else die?
Oh, is she going for the camera?
Wait, where is she?
Where did she go?
Oh my God.
Oh my God, that was...
You're crazy.
You don't have an arm.
No!
What happened to you?
Dang it, that guy got me on the ladder.
I was like, oh, I wonder if he'll be able to attack you.
Oh, I was wondering, because you were right behind me.
Yeah.
How did you die?
I got eaten by a dog.
Oh, you got eaten by the dog.
Oh, the big guy got you on the ladder?
That sucks.
Oh, there's your photo.
Oh my God, that is a kudosa.
I'm eating my ass.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Damn, that one's so scary.
That's like a true apocalyptic...
When you chomp, you're the Darwin of war.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, yeah.
I still survived.
I survived that guy twice, and I survived the baby.
I like this one, too.
The rat just ran towards you and didn't even stop.
He just took your leg out.
Oh my God, I wish I saw...
He smelled my blood.
I wish I could have shown you guys.
I wish it caught on camera.
You got a selfie with the big guy.
Oh my God, he did.
Wait, did it even count?
It didn't register as being with him, but it sucked.
Oh, you got robbed.
I did.
This was supposed to be a photo with the rat right through you, but you were so fast.
This was the rat mowing you down.
And it was so fast, I didn't capture the moment.
I look like I'm really angry.
Are you sure I should do that?
I love this photo.
This is when I was peeping into people's houses.
Oh, you really did take a photo.
Alright, your turn with the pro camera.
Oh God, I don't know if I can handle this responsibility.
It's your turn.
Give me the flashlight if you want.
Yeah, take the flashlight.
Alright.
Another day on the job.
Do we have a standard flashlight?
I do, I do.
I have one.
Let's go.
I didn't have one before.
You did, I didn't get it though.
I was too busy getting your camera.
Don't worry, we're all professionals here.
I knew my journalism degree would come in handy.
I don't have a journalism degree.
Who is reading this newspaper?
Who's still alive to be reading this?
I wonder what the blue light means.
I feel like it has to be important, but it hasn't told us anything about it yet.
Well, I feel like now that the internet is down and everything, you know, this is like literally...
literally like the only thing to read now.
Oh, true.
I feel like, yeah, I'm pretty sure these monsters have taken down all of the internet.
The 5G's.
The 5G?
The 5G rays that's turning the frogs gay.
Even if the world ends, even if the world ends, we still got you covered.
BS insurance.
We are professionals.
Which way do you want to go?
There's a building behind us.
Oh, we didn't go to that building.
Mint and I went in there very briefly, but not long enough, so we can go look.
Yeah, let's look in there.
No, I think it's all like randomly generated.
Yeah.
Don't go crypto.
Well, this is different.
Uh oh.
Wanna get rich?
Sure.
Hello.
We're here to get rich.
I ain't scared.
It's really dark in here.
Oh, hey, there's CCTV.
I wonder if it ever actually shows anything useful.
I don't think so.
Hello, intercom.
Hello.
It's scary not having the flashlight, actually.
I know, it is.
I don't think there's anything else in here.
There are no more doors here?
There's a door across from us over there.
Oh yeah, let's go over there, yeah.
Ooh.
Hello?
Oh, we're in the news station.
Channel 5 News here to report on these alien sightings.
I guess this is another news station.
Oh, oh, what's that?
That's me.
Uh oh, wait, what's that sound?
Oh, someone creepy's here.
Baby!
I got him, I got him!
I got the baby, I got the baby!
Let me fuckin' squeeble.
I got a little squeeble.
Who would pose next to it?
He's apparently chasing us, so we might wanna be...
Oh god, oh god, I'm running, I'm running.
That's right, can't get my legs if I'm on high ground.
I'm jumpin', I'm jumpin' down.
Hey, you guys good?
Yeah!
Yeah, he can't get me.
I'mma have the high ground now.
Yeah,
we have all the good photos.
Wait, there's something over there, do you see that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'll take a picture of that.
I'll pose next to it.
Yeah,
we're just chillin'.
We're just chill, guys.
Was it the baby?
Was it a squeaker?
I don't think it was a squeaker.
Oh shit!
We opened the door.
Oh yeah, we got that.
Oh, there's a dead guy there too.
Uh oh, I hear him, I hear him.
I hear him walking.
There's enough room for three people up here, Lyon.
Oh, there's something on the stairwell up there.
Oh, they're all up here.
Through that door over there, yeah.
There are camping guys!
This is New York, look, this is New York.
We should skedaddle.
We should really leave.
How do we get out?
Oh, let's go up the stairway here.
Aren't they camping?
No, through the door.
I think to get out, we go back this way?
We come from here?
This looks right.
Cause we closed all the doors.
And there was a lantern.
Yeah, yeah, and then up here.
Uh-huh.
See?
I would never lead you astray with my horrific sense of direction.
Wait, this is the exit over here.
Yeah, okay.
This way, yeah.
Do we want to leave?
I think we might.
What is that?
I don't know, do you want a photo of it before we go?
Yeah, sure, last photo before we go.
It's kinda stompy.
Yeah, I was gonna say, it's big, it's a big boy.
Oh, there it is!
It's a stalker!
Stalker, no stalking!
Oh wait, his name is Shamble.
Oh, I missed it.
Oh, two posts, two posts next to him.
Uh, I'm out of photos.
Eh, running.
Go, go, go, go!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
There's a dog right next to you, you're gonna die.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Something ran underneath me.
Oh my god!
Big
guy coming through.
Everyone get out!
I swear, you guys have to get this camera.
I would run it very far away.
When I die with this camera.
I think she's dead.
She's right here.
Your body- Oh wait, no, these are military bodies.
I might die, I might die, I-
Don't come here.
Don't come this way.
I don't know where her body is, but I'm running.
I'm leaving.
Wait, is she dead?
Wait, where did Lime go?
Oh!
I was like, did Lime die?
I didn't know she died!
Okay, I'll just get in the plane first and wait for it.
There's my photo, there's a photo of you.
These are gonna be the only photos we have because we died.
There's the beautiful cab, and then there's the stalker, and then wow, the baby right there.
And then, look at that.
All me, guys.
Oh, and I took us to the next level.
You're welcome, everybody.
Look at that.
My beautiful photo.
My beautiful photo in the front page.
Yet again.
Look at that.
MVP.
We need a pro camera.
Okay.
We could also do like a...
We could each have pro cameras.
Oh, that's true.
But that does lower the amount of total photos we can take because it could only hold seven.
Oh.
Yeah, that's like the disadvantage.
We could get like sports shoes so we could run faster.
We could get more health too.
We could get a pair of sports shoes and then we could also maybe get a flashy camera because that's like a good middle ground.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so let's do sports shoes and a flashy camera.
I can't believe I lived there.
That monster killed all the military men and I lived.
I watched it and I was like oh, she's dead for sure.
Yeah, I thought I was dead.
I wasn't looking at my screen anymore.
I was like goodbye.
Alright, who wants the shoes?
Who wants the camera?
Don't let Doki take the... Okay, nevermind.
He's just gonna use it to run away You cannot do it.
I think Lime should do it because she's been the camera picker up here.
Alright.
Sick kicks, we're going.
Okay, I'll get it.
You'll also have to like, you know, we don't have a flashlight because I mismanaged our money so let's go.
I have a flashlight here.
Oh, you have a flashlight?
Fantastic.
Someone else use it, not me.
I got it, I got it.
We're good, we're good.
Alright, let's go.
We should be in...
Yeah, we're in crime level 3 now, I'm pretty sure.
Monster crime.
Yeah.
Those monsters.
God damn it.
Ever since that monster became mayor prime levels have risen.
Those monsters ruined the neighborhood.
Yeah, these monsters ruined the neighborhood.
I got him.
Yeah, it's got an inbuilt flash.
Medicines, all of them.
They're not, they're monsters!
We're like the people in Townsville.
Isn't like people in Townsville like hate monsters and don't want to integrate?
The city of Townsville.
That's right.
They don't deserve to work in our city.
Oh, there's a building over to the right here.
On the left.
Do you want to go to the city mall or whatever that building is?
Don't think it matters.
I feel like this one's closer, just a little bit.
Yeah, but it's the same, we've been here before.
Yeah, it's the international.
Yeah, yeah.
Why don't we get access to the elevator?
Oh, I hear growling.
Oh, there's a dude just hiding over there.
Oh, nevermind, that's a man.
Help!
Someone, someone, did someone...
I got you.
I got a photo, don't worry, I got the photo.
Oh, it's the fucking baby.
That bitch.
What's he doing?
Baby!
Hey, get out of my shot, man.
I mean, he can't see points.
Alright, I...
Don't worry, I'm okay, guys, if you were wondering.
Yeah, we're all great.
Was that the baby that got me?
I didn't even see him.
I don't know.
It was a trap.
Oh, baby!
Oh my god, he just ran.
How is there so many monsters right off the bat?
I know.
Kids were on three stars.
Hello, babies.
Wait, Poe's next to the baby.
Oh, nevermind, he ran away.
Goodbye, baby.
Goodbye, little man.
I vote we don't just chase the baby.
Nah.
Oh, shit!
What is it?
Baby!
Where?
What did you see?
It was a stalker.
Remember the stalker that came up to you and went, Oh.
I think he might be like that guy in Lethal Company where you have to see him in order for him not to murder you.
Like, you know, you catch him and then...
Yeah.
Oh!
It was a stalker again.
What's going on in there?
Squishy noises.
We should photograph those squishy noises.
Hello.
If you feel close to the thing, always emote.
Just press it.
Just remember to emote.
Oh, the baby killed him!
What the fuck?
I'm now terrified of the baby.
Oh, God.
What the fuck?
The baby is afraid of light, I think.
Oh, my God!
The perfect photo!
The baby killed the fucking stalker, though.
Yeah, the baby...
The baby is awesome!
Thanks, baby!
He's just standing there.
Oh, I can move this.
Oh, damn.
We can take it.
Oh, we can take it for a better photo.
Ugh.
Oh, he's so...
Okay, he doesn't stop, like, squishing once you pick him up.
Oh, there's a goop here.
Oh.
I don't want to step on that, personally.
Put him on it.
No.
Why are you following us, dude?
You have, like, no self-preservation instincts whatsoever.
Maybe he can step through it.
Are we just parkour here?
Oh, true.
YOLO.
I fell down.
So, I think the baby might get real scary if you don't have any light.
Yeah.
Cause the baby just fucking brutalized that thing.
Yeah, that...
I thought he was just a real man, but, like, he is a big boy.
Oh, the holder.
Uh-oh, what was that?
It's him, right there.
Hey, there.
He's chilling.
He's just chilling.
Oh, he's gonna vibrate?
Bye.
He's like, peace out.
He does a spin.
That's what he does.
He's just there for the vibe.
Where do we go now, after this?
He's still following us.
I know.
Are you okay, man?
I think he's gonna follow us until we, like, get out of the house.
The house.
I'd hate for this to be my house.
Yeah, my big-ass house right here.
Oh, Jesus.
Hello again.
Who was that?
It was the boy.
Oh, it's him again.
Yeah, he's just chilling.
I don't really understand his bit.
Oh, what is that?
It's him again, isn't it?
That's the same sound.
It sounds like him, yeah.
Yeah.
Whoa, baby.
Meow.
Oh, this leads to the main entrance.
Oh, does it?
Oh, we should go back.
I think it should be enough time for a big guy to show up.
Oh, yeah, this is where that dude died.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should go back there.
We're going in a circle now.
Yeah, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Hello.
We didn't go this way.
It seems like he killed the other thing, so...
Yeah, there's not a whole lot in here anymore.
Yeah, I feel like it's just a baby now.
Just one whole baby.
Oh, he's here.
And he's out, yep.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Oh.
Wait, I'll do a pose.
Oh, there's a mini man.
There's a mini man.
Please, if I die, take my photo.
If I die, take my picture!
I'm safe.
Oh, I don't think I'm safe.
Oh!
Please turn around, sir.
Turn around!
Running, running, running, running, running, running, running, Winning, winning, winning, winning, winning, winning, winning, winning...
The men make it!
Oh no!
There was the equivalent of a trapdoor spider popped out of a fucking...
Oh my god.
You guys didn't get my camera!
I know I didn't get your camera!
Oh you did?
Okay...
That's what her shoes are for!
That's why!
That was amazing!
I saw that manhole cover moving and I was like, Oh, that's weird.
Then you went over there and got the fork.
I didn't even see!
I was like, what killed me?
Nothing was around!
I took a picture of it.
You'll see it in a second.
Oh, no.
Yes, I know exactly what you're talking about.
I saw it pop up, too.
Yeah, that's the photo.
That.
That guy.
Yeah, I saw that.
What on earth?
I didn't even see that guy.
That's me!
Would you see him?
That was the biggest monster!
What do you mean?
Alright, my...
Your camera should be back on the desk.
My favorite photo has to be this one.
Oh, is it permanent?
No, it's because I picked it up for you.
Oh, that's right.
It just returns it to the desk.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's right.
Oh, yeah, here's when you were getting trapped, by the way.
Oh, yeah, that's what it looked like.
Yeah, yeah, you were like, what's going on?
I like how he got six shoes on as well.
It looks like that fucking Fortnite thing where you can change your six shoes no matter who you are now.
It looks like that.
And there's the baby.
I thought that thing was gonna pop back out of the manhole and eat me when I tried to get your camera.
Oh my god, I didn't realize there were like fucking traps too in the manhole.
That's crazy.
I didn't either.
That's so evil.
That's where you died.
I know.
Man, I thought it was the military guys shot me or something.
Oh, no, no, the bullets go through you.
They do?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got shot.
Like, they shot me, but I was like, I lived.
It would be kind of harsh if you got friendly fired by those dudes on top of everything else.
I know!
Yeah, yeah, I was gonna say that would be pretty fucking rough.
Wait, you didn't see that giant tree monster?
No, I was legitimately like trying to deal with someone that was throwing cars at me.
That's crazy.
You were just like, we just gotta run.
You still have the flashlight, right?
Oh, you do?
Yeah, we got a flashlight.
Okay, I wanna go to a different house.
I feel like we've explored that a lot already.
There was one on the right, but it seems as though the insides are just randomized.
I think so.
Wait, is there anything over here?
There's like a little alleyway.
You could also go up, but I don't think you can get onto the building.
I'm not sure.
I feel like it's just the Rutov, like, perspective POV.
Yeah, can we get inside?
I assume not, but...
This feels like it's, like, lit up for me to go into, but no.
There's, like, weird lighting everywhere, too.
Like, this yellow lighting here.
Game design rules tell me I should be able to get inside that hut, but they lied to me.
Wait, I think we just went in a circle a little bit.
Yeah, we did.
We went to the alleyway.
We don't wanna go to Sushi Kyoto!
Why can't we go there?
Oh, there's somebody in there.
Oh, yeah, they won't let us in Sushi Kyoto.
He's like, no, this is my Sushi Kyoto.
Wait, there's another house over there we haven't gone to.
Uh-huh.
What, this one right here?
Some people are saying we might actually make it to level 5.
Really?
We're gamers.
Oh, we're gamers.
Oh, oh, it's this area again.
Oh, there's a little rat.
Yeah, I think they're randomized.
Oh, the stalker!
Fuck off, stalker!
Stalker, no stalking!
Oh, I didn't get to see a picture of... Oh, there he is!
Wait, there's a trap.
There's a string trap nearby.
How do you know?
I took a picture and...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, look on the ceiling, I think, is where you'll see.
Yeah, I don't see it, though.
I don't either.
Just knock me down if it gets me, I guess.
Oh, there's a weird humpback tick thing!
Ew!
What?
It was on here.
Whoa, stalker!
Stalker behind, stalker behind!
I got him.
Oh, there he is.
What the fuck is that?
What the hell is that?
I told you, it's a weird humpback tick!
Oh!
Do a pose!
Do a flip!
I'm gonna point at him.
Where he going?
Look at him go!
Oh my, I see ya.
Oh, I could selfie that.
Shambles?
Oh, I hear something on the left.
There's a lot of stuff down here.
There's more threats here, guys.
There's a lot of threats here.
We don't even need to leave this front room.
I think we could just stay in here and...
Stalker, no stalking!
I like the stalker.
The rat's in here.
Oh wait, no, this is a headcrab.
Oh my god, what the fuck is that?
Oh, what was that?
Oh, okay, nevermind.
You cannot take a picture of it through the glass, so we would need to go in there.
Wait, there's a...
Rat, rat, rat, rat!
Rat!
Oh my god, where is he trying to go?
He's diseased!
Alright.
Do you wanna try and get the headcrab?
I have a feeling as soon as that door opens, we're gonna be in trouble.
Okay, we're just letting him in.
Someone's...
God damn it!
Nice.
I got it.
I got the photo.
It's on the floor.
Thank you.
It's okay guys, I got the photo.
Oh, I didn't even die!
Oh, I'm out of...
I'm out of film now.
Dang it.
Weird tick creature's back!
He's gone.
He went off to the left.
I feel like we definitely...
Oh!
Something just died, I think.
Ah!
Whoa!
Rattler!
Dang!
There's something else in here?
It's like a big guy.
Ratt's coming back!
Watch your feet, watch your feet!
Where is he?
He just ran to the end of the room you guys went into.
Oh.
There's so many monsters here.
Hunchback tick creature thing.
Oh, he's just chillin'.
He's coming after me.
Can you take a photo with him?
Oh god!
I'm running.
He's coming after me.
In a really slow kinda way.
Woo!
Don't get us!
I'm a journalist!
I have a...
I have a journalist pass!
I'm journalist immunity!
Wait, where's the...
Oh, at four I left.
Maybe big guy will show up.
I feel like big guy should be outside now.
Oh no!
He's here!
You need to get a good perspective picture.
I'm trying to get out!
Wait.
Guys.
Our plane is on the other side.
No it's not.
Oh.
Guys.
You're right.
Guys, we locked ourselves in.
Oh god.
Oh no.
He lost interest.
We're so tiny.
Okay.
I think we can head back, right?
Yeah.
I feel like we wanna get...
Oh.
Hey.
Hey guys.
He's coming back, guys.
Oh.
Just kidding.
He's coming.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Guys, he's still here.
Are they dead?
Are they alive?
Is the safety come on?
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, there's a rat.
Oh my god.
What choice?
He's just camping me!
I can't get out!
He's literally there!
Okay.
Please, please, please, please.
There's so many.
There's so many monsters.
How do I get through?
Okay.
Okay, I can make it.
I can make it.
Guys, he's literally outside the door.
He's outside.
Okay.
Okay, I can make it.
I can make it.
Oh my god, he's right here.
Oh!
No!
I'm gonna everywhere.
They were everywhere!
Mint and I got pressed through the world.
Yeah, we actually clipped Noclip through the map.
Wait, what?
There's a photo in Discord where I'm just looking up at the floor from below.
Yes, yes.
Oh my god, they were everywhere.
We got Noclip'd into oblivion.
There's nowhere to go.
Yeah, I was like, girl, I'm doing well.
I hesitated.
There was so many monsters everywhere.
I didn't know what to do.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're totally gonna get all 3,000 points that we need in this one run.
We can do it.
Whoever said...
We have two runs.
Oh, never mind.
No, this is our last run.
Whoever said we were gonna get to level five, they cursed us.
They cursed us.
We had such a good run, too.
Dang.
We all have to use all our photos.
We have to use...
We have to take as much as we can.
And make sure we don't get doublose, too.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
We got this.
No, our nice camera...
Gone.
Okay, there was like five fucking monsters outside my door.
Like, how the fuck was I gonna get out of there?
It's such a shame because...
Because we Noclipped through the planet, it dumped our bodies by the helicopter and our cameras.
So you could've like...
Oh my god, really?
Everything was right there.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
The big stock...
Oh my...
If the big red guy didn't block the only way across, I would've ran.
Yeah.
I feel like we should go to the door to the right side.
That had so many monsters.
Sure, sure.
Last time...
Okay, this one right here?
Yeah, the right side.
Okay.
Oh wow, the truck is already overturned.
Ew.
But it's okay, I can move it with my head, apparently.
Yeah, you can push it.
It gives us a little bit of a cover.
Yeah, that's true.
Alright, I'm coming with you.
Alright, let's go.
And there's something zooming around at the top.
Oh, I see it.
There's something at the top, do you see it?
Oh, yeah, I see it.
Oh, there's like two things up there.
I'm posing, I'm posing.
Oh, what the fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
I don't like that.
Everything's wobbling.
Polpo.
It's like a spider, man.
His name is Polpo, apparently.
Polpo!
Hey, Polpo.
Yo, Polpo.
What you doing?
I cannot see anything.
It's so fucking dark.
We are so dead.
You can see a little bit better through your camera lens.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing, too.
But then you're gonna waste the battery.
Oh, you don't waste battery.
The thing is just the camera film.
Oh, it is?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's not battery.
Oh.
Oh, God, it's a little vent gremlin.
Great.
And a stalker.
And another vent gremlin.
Leave me alone.
Oh my God.
What are you gonna do, huh?
This guy's a dick.
Oh, he'll take your leg out.
Yeah, he will actually.
Yeah, bye, but a high ground.
He fucking murdered me.
It was really funny.
Oh, there's something in there.
Oh, it's another.
It's the vent crawler again.
Hey, buddy.
No, vent crawler.
Okay, let me...
This guy sucks.
God, I had so many good photos, too, last time.
He's coming.
Oh, there he is.
Ugh.
Um...
Not sure about that one, friends.
Oh, mom.
I didn't get it.
What happened to my legs?
I don't know.
Should we try and take...
Like, wait for the big guys to show up and take photos outside or something?
Do I still have my leg?
No.
Well, you do.
Mint does not.
I don't.
Oh, okay.
I'm okay, too.
I'd like to get a picture of the stalker.
Oh, there's another fucking beholder in here, too.
A what?
Go away, vent crawler.
Okay, at, like, six minutes, we have to get out, because that's when the big guy spawns in, I feel.
Okay.
Mm-mm.
Where's the military when we need them?
What's the point of funding the military when they don't show up when we want them to?
Hello?
Has anybody come out?
I think we're safe now.
Oh, never mind.
I didn't realize we had to zoom in.
You see that little guy?
I'm such an idiot.
What do you mean?
You haven't been zooming in?
Hello?
What was that?
Are you guys...
Good now?
Hello?
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Oh, there's the stalker.
I got him.
I didn't.
I didn't get him.
I got him.
We have to, like, pretend we can't see him, so he gets closer.
He's really annoying.
Gotta like it.
Well, I sure hope no big stalker comes and sneaks up behind me.
I don't notice him.
Hope you're ashamed if someone just shows up behind me.
I'd sure hate it if a...
I'm so...
If a vent crawler ate my ass right now.
I'm so vulnerable.
I actually would hate that.
I don't feel like it might open.
I'm alone at night right now.
And I'm shaking my booty.
Oh, what's gonna happen?
I think we should split up and go in different directions.
Hey, guys.
Let's split up and look for clues.
No, let's split up and look for clues.
I've already split...
Oh, there's a little zoomer guy in there.
Zuma, zuma, zuma, zuma.
Oh, I forget to...
That whole thing is...
I'm scared.
We're not gonna...
Oh, there's another zoomer.
I don't really know what this guy does.
I don't know.
The answer seems to be not anything.
Oh!
Stalker, no stalking!
No!
I got quite a few points from him.
I must...
Oh, what's that?
Did you see that?
I'm not getting any of these.
What the hell?
Do you see that on the other side?
No.
Jump, jump.
Do you see that?
Where the fuck is the...
The Pope is still over there.
There he is.
Hey, Pope, come say hi.
No.
Alright, we should go out.
It's five-minute mark.
Don't be shy, Pope.
Okay.
It's a five-minute mark.
He should be outside now.
Oh!
Oh, there's soldiers!
There's a big guy.
We should try and take photos outside the helicopter or something.
I can't run!
Run!
Wait.
Oh shit, to our side!
Don't worry, I got the photo!
You're ganked!
Where did you...
She's still here!
This lady is faster than me.
Because you're not gonna flank.
This is where...
It all comes down to this.
If we make enough...
If we make enough money...
No, you didn't!
It all comes down to our 30 photos.
Our 30 photos.
Let's go.
Alright.
I believe.
The drama.
What the fuck?
It worked!
That's a really good one.
Thank you.
That's a nice one.
Okay, that's good.
That's a good one.
Oh, that's the cat!
Yeah!
Yay!
It should be enough, I think.
Hell yeah!
We made it!
Yeah, plus 5,000!
I like how...
Both selfies...
God, look at that.
Guys, three out of...
Three out of four...
Our headliners!
I personally like this one better than this one.
Yeah, I actually like that one.
Yeah, that one looks good.
Do you wanna do...
A flashy camera?
There's also an SD camera that gives you 15 pictures.
Whoa!
I feel like more photos is good.
Sure, okay.
We have $200.
What do you wanna spend it on?
Another camera or...
Some normal flashlights?
Oh, bravery.
I got bravery points.
We could give each other helmets.
We could spend two helmets for health.
Oh, I see it.
What about sports shoes?
You know, I'm gonna order some helmets.
Cuz you know when you get attacked by a Venn creature that eats your leg?
Yeah?
I think having a helmet on will save your life.
Oh yeah, yeah, that's a good idea.
It's basically the same body part, so...
Wait, you don't need to wear the helmet?
Oh, I forgot the helmet.
Alright, I think...
Well, you have to...
You don't just wear the helmet.
Oh, no, you do.
I think it's because it's an item that you have to hold to get the benefit.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, you have it.
It's my special helmet.
Oh, it says press on the back.
Wait, you don't have it on.
Is it on?
No, there's only two.
Yeah, yours is.
Well, you guys need it the most.
No, you two need it.
Me?
Really?
I mean, you're constantly trying to, like, suicide for photos.
It's the most responsible here.
So, we are one with the helmets.
It's our special helmet.
Wait, how do I equip it?
Okay, does someone have the camera that takes tons of pictures?
Wait, how do you...
Yeah, here.
How do I equip this?
No, that's fine.
You take it.
How do I equip this?
Just having it causes it to be yours.
Yeah.
Oh, is it on my head now?
When you scroll off of it, it will be.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
You're good.
Hey, guys.
Okay.
My mom bought this helmet for me for the bus.
Let's go!
Wait, before we go, I need to use the bathroom.
I've been hydrating.
Got it.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Is it Thursday?
No, it's Wednesday today, isn't it?
It's Wednesday, yeah.
My sense of time is all messed up because I've been sick.
I've not been streaming on my normal day.
So I'm like, what fucking day is it?
Are you getting proper rest?
No, I've spent most of the time trying to sleep and then not being able to sleep because I can't breathe.
And then falling asleep because I'm so tired.
So it's like all over the place.
Yeah!
It's the worst!
I have like no concept of time anymore.
Because I'll try and go to bed and then I'll lie there from like 2am to 9am.
And I'm so tired and I didn't get any sleep.
And then I'll get up and I'll go and sit down in a chair.
And I'll fall asleep in the chair instead for 3 hours.
And then I wake up and it's 6pm and I'm like, what the fuck?
But if you're in the chair, you're like sitting up.
Maybe that helps your nose.
Yeah, no.
When I'm sitting up, I'm less clogged.
So it's nicer, I think.
Oh, you sound terrible.
Thanks.
Yeah, I was sick not too long ago.
I get it.
Hello, I'm back.
Welcome back.
Did you wash your hands?
Yeah, I washed my hands.
Thanks, mom.
Awesome.
Proud of you.
We're the two daughters that need helmets.
We need helmets on the bus.
It's back to Times Square, but it's more dangerous.
God, you look like my...
My two kids who I don't trust enough to have in safety.
Yeah, we have the leashes on too.
The hardest is in everything.
You're pulling us...
What?
Die already!
How?
You were alive for 30 seconds.
Well, get home and find us.
I ran into a
car.
Have you ever been run over by a parked car?
I got run over by a parked car!
What the fuck?
I wonder if someone was like underneath the car.
I don't think there was.
I think she literally just got physics to death.
You know in like Source games where something's like vibrating and it causes you to take like...
Velocity collision damage?
I think she did that with a car.
I need a stronger helmet.
Let's go in here.
It'll be funny.
Why is it making creepy noises?
I don't know, I'm gonna die.
It's a horrible noise.
It's not fair.
Do you want the special camera that you have?
Because I got the flashlight, so here you go.
Okay.
I take more photos.
I trust you with it.
You'll be great.
Oh, we're in the same room as both of them.
What the fuck?
Oh, hey Cthulhu.
What's our beholder?
I get them mixed up sometimes.
That helmet...
That helmet was fucking made of plastic.
Oh, look.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
I'm so excited with my helmet.
I'm just trying to figure out what that weird bleeping noise is.
I was so excited.
I was ready to explore a new world with my mom and sister.
Oh, that's not terrifying at all.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Alrighty then.
I literally was like...
This DJ card took me out.
Wait, is it?
I think it's that.
Oh my gosh, it's a...
Oh, there are mines.
We're truly the most lethal of companies right now.
Oh my god.
This is level three.
Leap loop.
Leap.
Leap boop.
I wish I was there.
Oh, I wanna sneeze like constantly.
It's fucking awful.
Oh, there's a dude being eaten.
That's cool.
Oh yeah, there is.
I can probably get a sick pose in front of it because of the height.
Yeah, let's get us both in there.
Oh, there's a guy in here for sure.
It's just a boulder.
Do you get a good picture?
Oh, he's coming up.
He's coming up.
Hey, what's up?
I wish I could be part of this.
I wish I could be part of the fun.
I mean, I get weird music when he looks at me, so maybe if you let him stare at you too long, bad stuff happens?
I don't know.
Ah, maybe.
I think, I kind of remember boulders, if you look at them, you go nuts, so maybe just, I don't know, don't stare at him.
I don't know.
Oh, he's up there too.
Oh, yeah, I'm starting to get tired.
Oh, he's gone again.
Or something weird.
Level three is so dangerous that even a car can...
Everything was fine before!
Oh, there's some goop I will overhear.
And that's a trap right there.
Or it was.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
That's kind of scrungly.
Just my luck.
Just my fucking luck, guys.
I think this is where we started.
I died from a parked car.
Just jokey things, guys.
Just jokey things.
I don't know.
Wait, what the fuck?
Turn around, look.
Impossible geometry.
It's a literal suicide door.
It's perfect for this moment, not gonna lie.
How many pictures did you get?
Do you think we should just go outside and take some pictures of the carnage outside?
I have eight out of fifteen left.
Alright.
Pretty nice.
I got tons of cameras.
You're right.
I didn't look both ways.
Oh, the big guys should be outside now.
Yeah, they should go out.
It's five minute mark.
Oh, there's another headcrab thingy.
Or, you know, like a head muncher.
Oh, they're outside.
Let me see you outside.
Go outside, go outside, guys!
Go outside!
Come on!
You think there's something sweet outside as a result?
Go outside, it's time.
It happens in the five minute mark.
I'm gonna go look.
Yeah, let's go look.
Holy shit!
Uh, hello?
Oh, what the fuck?
That's a tornado!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Another side, oh my god!
I hate that.
He's just looking.
He's tossing shit at us, what a dick.
Wouldn't it be funny if it hits them right there?
There's a car.
They're literally right next to each other.
He can actually get a 2K right here.
We can just hang out here and take some pictures and then whoever dies first, you pick up their camera and just leave.
They're literally like, oh my god, they're next to each other.
It's gonna be a 2K.
He literally could get 2 kills in one hit.
He's running towards the tornado, which is like an interesting battle strategy.
He's just there, yes.
I don't know if it's gonna work out for him.
Great survival instincts.
Take a selfie, take a selfie, guys!
I gotta get closer to it.
Okay, maybe you could pose or something, I'll take a picture of you.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm posing.
Uh, turn back towards me, there we go.
Sick picture.
Yeah!
I can't join the party.
Oh, there's a monster, there's like a stompy monster over there.
Oh, there's a couple actually.
His name is Clubby.
I can't join the party.
He's got a club.
I'm just in the corner watching.
Well,
I have two more, so I guess I'll just take some...
Yeah, I mean, we can wait a couple more minutes, see if anything cool shows up in the last minute or two.
This guy isn't very threatening.
No.
He's actively moving away from us while staring us down in impotence.
He's actually the least threatening monster out of all of them.
He looks like he should be so intimidating, but nothing's happened.
Yeah, I mean, it was really scary when we spawned right next to him, and then he was like, oh, I'm sorry, I'll move for you.
Just get a vacuum, guys, come on.
Suck him up.
There's nobody here either, it's just kinda chill.
Just be careful of the car that killed Doki, I guess.
Oh yeah, don't touch the car.
The car casualty.
Hey Doki, are you still inhabiting your dead body over here?
I'm out of photos.
I'm getting in, cause I'm out of photos.
It's okay.
We'll remember you.
They're just dancing, I'm dead and she's just dancing.
Dancing.
I brought Doki with us.
What bright side, there's no bright side.
I didn't even get to play the game.
I didn't get to play the game.
We're gonna protect you with your safety helmets, and then you won't get to a stationary car and fucking die.
Here's your helmet back, Doki.
I just thought it was funny.
Oh, that's a good photo.
I like how it's just selfies of you and the big guy.
I mean, he was really considerate, he just chilled and let us do our thing.
Oh, that's a good one.
That photo's good.
That's a really cool one.
Oh, 4,000, wow.
50% of it on the first one.
Your helmet's back by the desk, Doki.
Okay, this helmet's made out of plastic, there's no way.
There's no way.
Wait, who has the blue camera?
There's a blue camera right there.
Oh, it's right here.
It's right there.
It respawned.
Oh, yeah, it respawned on my bed.
Alright, I'll use it then.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go.
Now I know cars are dangerous no matter what.
Never get in a car, guys.
Never get on top of a car.
Cars, not even ones.
Don't do it.
I'm pretty sure you bought this helmet from a kid's section.
Already?
50 % already.
Yeah.
Alright, avoid this.
He's a raccoon!
Hey mister, did you know if you chat with me, you can get a good deal on your vehicle insurance?
Don't say I didn't do nothing for you.
Is there something over here?
Hello?
I'm curious, if we just stay outside the whole time, how things start appearing.
If they do, at least.
Like, you know?
Oh, that's true.
I mean, we could.
I wonder.
It's at the 5 minute mark.
There's a building, do you see?
Someone should go and camp that building and take really cool aerial shots.
Oh, that's true.
Do you see that ladder over there?
Yeah, I can do that.
Wait, there's also a door over here.
Yeah, there is.
That's TV.
Oh yeah, so someone stay outside and the other people get photos just in case, like, something terrible happens when you just camp outside and we lose the run.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, exclusion.
Oh, okay.
I'll stay outside.
Of course you will.
Come on, mid, let's go be brave.
Yeah, let's go do actual jobs.
You guys suggested that!
Don't worry, guys.
I'll get the coolest shots out there.
Oh my god, so cool.
Look at me, mom.
Wait.
Okay, what?
Oh, wait.
What emote should I do?
I should do that.
Look at that.
It's like I'm like a tourist right now.
My 18 points.
I'm like a little tourist.
Oh, I hope I don't fall.
I hope I don't accidentally fall.
Oh, wait, how do I get down?
Okay, it's right here.
I won't accidentally fall.
There's no way.
Alright, let's see.
There is black and white codex.
Where maximum performance it lives.
Like, it was the last day.
Oh, look at that!
Step into debt one pair at a time.
I wonder when they start appearing though.
It's at five minutes, right?
Should be five or six minutes.
Oh, that's like McDonald's.
WhackDonald's.
So sweet that you will be diabetic.
Look around you.
The world is different.
I believe in this.
There's no way I'll die here.
I feel so safe.
I honestly wonder how he appears though.
Wait.
Oh, I can't get the cool selfie here.
Wait, is he dead?
Okay.
Oh, they're dead dead.
Oh, goodbye.
I don't think he sees me up here.
What do you mean Doki doesn't know?
What do you mean by that?
I'm so safe.
Oh, it's six minutes.
I wonder how he appears though.
There's like gunshots here.
There's like...
Guys, I've covered wars, you know.
Look at that.
I have battlefield photos.
That's when you know I got the experience.
Where did he even come from?
Where did this big guy even come from?
We're getting closer.
Oh, there he is.
Wait.
I feel like I hear ghosts right now.
I wonder where they are.
Oh shit, what the fuck is that?
Oh my god, the fuck is that?
Oh, is that the alien dog?
Oh shit.
Okay, but where's the tornado?
Where's the tornado?
Oh, there he is.
Come on, there he is.
Okay, it's time to go.
It's time to go.
I'm scared.
Oh, there's the other.
Don't worry, I'm gonna be the hero.
As soon as I figure out how to get down from here.
It's okay.
I'm gonna be the last one alive.
That's right, it's your turn to watch me.
Okay.
Cool.
Alright, don't worry, I got three more of these.
Don't worry.
I'm doing it for you guys.
And then...
Ta-da!
Alright.
It's so hard being me sometimes.
I did it.
It's so hard being me.
I'm a hero.
I did it, guys.
What happened?
We found out what the beholder does.
If he manages to get close enough to you when he spins, he explodes.
Oh, wait, did you guys all explode?
I got it all, but you died.
Our camera is doing it.
What a hero.
Don't worry, guys.
I got us the photos we needed.
Look at that.
I got that.
And then I did that.
And then...
Another one of the tornadoes.
Yeah, but I got us 3,000 points, though.
Don't worry, everybody.
No need to thank me.
No need to thank me, guys.
I'm just being a hero that we deserve.
Hey,
guys.
We still have our SD camera.
I will remember this, Doki.
I will remember this.
I had some cool photos, too, but I died.
We all died when we had some really cool photos.
You died to a car.
I don't wanna hear it.
It was a very scary car.
I wonder if I could just...
Hold on.
Could it just happen at any time?
What?
You did something special.
I just ran straight into that car and nothing happened.
No, no.
You have to run in the front of the car.
In the front of the car.
Her body, her skin, and her paper, and her...
Okay.
Look.
Yeah, my bones are very fragile.
I don't know...
That looks like a scary car right there.
It's super pretty.
Look at this.
We've never been here.
This is new.
This is so awesome.
Wait, could we see the...
Could we see the guy spawn from the side?
I don't think so.
We'll hear the siren and stuff.
Yeah, the siren basically says he spawns, which is cool.
He spawns at the five minute mark.
Everything makes me think of her.
Suggie.
I like this layout.
Yeah, I like it too.
Snom.
Which way do we go?
We have no flashlight, so...
We have to look through our camera.
I'm going to follow Mint because clearly she knows what she's doing and now hasn't died multiple times.
I go in for...
The thrill.
The scoop.
The scoop of it all.
That's why she has the purple heart in journalism.
Purple heart in journalism.
It's not chocolate, it's not vanilla, it's mint chocolate chip, baby.
That's the scoop.
Oh, we just went in a big circle.
Where are the monsters?
Oh yeah, it was really good.
Great journalism, everybody.
Can we hear it?
I keep thinking that's an Enderman.
Oh wait, there's so much blood over here.
Where?
You hear the music?
Yeah, I do too.
Yeah.
I don't hear music.
It's like a...
Wait, there's body parts here.
I don't hear music.
Are you guys having a mass hallucination right now?
No, I do.
It's to the right.
Listen to the coffee.
Did you just say listen to the coffee?
That's what this says.
Yeah, I'm not crazy.
I thought it was the pizza.
You're advancing madness or some shit.
Listen to the coffee.
Do you hear the music?
I don't hear music.
Alright, ladies first.
This dark might get you fucking nothing though.
Yeah, it was like one point.
Oh, there's a beholder in that room.
Do not let him get close.
That guy's a dick.
Hey, go away.
Go away.
He might start chasing after us though.
Wait, does that what he does?
He chases?
Yeah, he does come after you.
Oh god, I'm starting to go a little bit cuckoo.
Okay, so I think you can't stare at him.
I think that's actually...
Oh, it's a CCTV room.
Yeah, there's no exit here.
I keep feeling like you can find loot in these places.
Oh, we have to go out soon.
It's almost five minutes.
Oh, what was that?
That's a mine.
Oh, I'm gonna take a picture of the mine.
Yeah, you can take a picture of it.
But it's not a lot of mines.
Oh, it's just 29.
Okay, we should go now.
Yeah.
A big guy shows up here.
A big guy.
Wait, how do we go back?
Is there really a point of going inside?
I wonder.
This area was very tame for a three-star.
Yeah.
Maybe everything's upstairs up here.
Oh no, it's a den.
Oh, seriously?
Oh.
Well, things seem chill.
He should spawn up soon, right?
There's a big guy over here if you want a picture in the meantime.
Oh, there is.
He's prowling around the cars.
Wait, where is he?
There's some dogs too, actually.
Oh, they're savaging some dudes.
Rest in peace.
Oh yeah, there's a big guy over there.
Wait, where's the turret?
Oh no.
Oh hey, you're alive.
What's up?
Wait, what happened?
What killed me?
It was the manhole thing.
It was over there.
Oh my god.
Did you get some pictures, miss?
No.
Well, I saw something fly.
I think I took a picture of something flying.
Doki got eaten by a manhole.
Wait, did she die?
I'm alive, bitch.
Almost.
There's a guy right in front of me.
Oh, and there's another guy right here.
We should leave.
I think the helmet...
I think it's right next... I think it spawned right next to where the...
I can run past it.
Oh, he's right next to the helicopter.
Okay.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
If we go heavily to the left, I think he can't go that way and he'll go past us.
I'm gonna go right side.
Okay, I go right, you go left.
Okay, Doki.
I'm gonna do it.
Where's the plane?
Oh, it's right here.
Yeah, I did it.
I was right.
How did I live through all of that?
Wait, where are they?
It was that easy.
Yeah, I told you.
I just walk around.
Oh, I don't think they're gonna... I'm gonna know if they made it or not soon.
I'm gonna figure out if they make it or not.
Oh,
I was dead?
See?
They're like, okay, Doki.
And then I'm the one who lives.
What do you mean?
I literally didn't... They didn't even trust me.
They didn't even trust my plan.
They decided to not listen to my plan.
I was like... I legit... I was just like...
Mint!
You fucking idiot!
Oh my god.
You just walked past.
I lived.
Get a camera.
You get a camera.
I lived.
You should've believed in me, Lime.
You should've... You did not believe in my plan.
Mine was the safest.
Your plan was literally, I'll go right, you go left.
So we went left, you went right.
That was your plan.
No, no.
You didn't believe... You did not believe in the power of the right side.
So I was like, okay, you left then.
You told us to go left.
I was scared.
No, no.
I was like, I'm gonna go right.
You guys didn't believe in my right side.
That was scary.
It was really good, actually.
The guy fucking sniped me with a car.
Oh my god.
I got hit by a car.
Yeah, you did.
I saw it happen.
Oh my god.
What's this?
Look at that.
Another selfie yet again.
Oh my god.
Look at the fucking selfie board.
The Frontline News selfies.
Another selfie headliner on the board.
Yeah, and everyone gets to see your fucking helmet.
My special helmet.
Everybody gets helmets.
I'm just saying, I'm just really good at the news.
What can I say?
Oh my god.
There you go.
Now we can all have helmets.
Look how many helmets we have.
Yay!
Our special!
Blue cameras for everybody too.
Oh wow, I have one too.
Repeated photo.
Do we see if they give us something cool and new on the next difficulty level?
Yeah, I see.
I think like every time we beat a level, we get to see a new monster.
Yeah, it seems to be the case.
Oh yeah, we're all special now.
We all have the special helmet.
Lime, you lost your hair.
Oh my, oh three, almost four.
Arthur's Square.
I have a photo of you dancing in front of the thing.
Oh hey, hey, remember this?
This is where we started.
Yay!
Back to the beginning.
I'm like scared of going near cars now.
I don't trust these.
I have PTSD.
I hear bars and ladders and...
Yeah, pretty much everything.
I mean, there's nothing in front of us.
This is a horrible map.
This is like a really difficult map to start people on.
Yeah.
Cause like it's so far away.
There's a building actually right across here.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, we haven't gone to that building yet.
It's called the Sarota Bank.
I wanna go to Sarota Bank.
I feel like we should all stay outside and like camp somewhere and then get the big monster when he comes.
Cowards.
Coward method.
Yeah, I meant you coward.
I would never do something like that.
Oh, it's a hotel lobby.
This building looks cool.
It's a lot hotel.
I like it.
You wanna stay outside and not see this amazing place?
I know right?
Look at this amazing hotel.
I mean, amazing is subjective.
That means like, that means there's vacancy guys.
We can get a suite for a discount.
Oh my god, we can get like the king suite.
A suite discount.
Whoa.
Okay, this just looks like an office now.
Now we're back in the studio.
We're back in the studio.
How do you feel?
Oh, there's the pupil.
He's right there.
Oh yeah, I see him.
What is it doing?
Wish it's closer, so I can get a better photo.
Ew.
He's like a little tarantula.
I don't even see him.
He's like right over here, under here.
Oh, I see him.
He's pupalulating.
He's like a little octopus.
Yeah.
Uh oh, he's going upstairs now.
Yeah, but he can't do anything.
He's just a...
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, he's leaving.
Oh, he just walked away.
See, I told you, he can't do anything.
Going through our exit.
The way we need to go.
I'm sure we won't have a problem when we need to leave.
There's usually a way around anyway.
Oh, there's like the skin mass here.
The stalagmites.
The alien stalagmites.
I feel like the building layouts in this game are a little bit better than Lethal Company.
In that if you go like more than 10 feet from the entrance, you don't get endlessly lost inside an infinite labyrinth and never get out again.
What I learned from Lethal Com...
Grab!
I got a cool photo though.
You got a 700 score photo because he was flying at my face.
We should go out now?
I got a 900 photo.
Me too.
I got one too.
Let's go.
That is a modified dog.
Can you pose for me?
Thank you.
Nice pose.
I like how the immediate pose is just like the fucking hands in the air.
Pose number 8, baby!
Oh,
hello.
Can you pose for me?
Nice.
Oh, nice, nice.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Was it here?
This was the way to do the shortcut, right?
It's not there anymore.
Wait.
There used to be a box there, I think.
Nope, still works.
Still works.
Oh, he's here.
Oh, it's the military men.
Where are they?
To the left.
I don't think they actually can.
There's our plane.
But, like, where's our... No, I don't think they can.
We gotta watch them die, though.
Over here in front of me.
Oh, there it is.
I got it.
I got the photo.
There's a...
Big dude with a fist behind us.
Oh, shit!
It's the big man again.
What's he gonna do?
Slap me?
He's gonna slap.
Is he slapping?
Oh, my God.
What are you doing right now?
What are you...
What are you doing?
Okay, I think we got the photos, right?
I'm leaving.
Alright, just selfie with him.
I got my 10.
Oh, my God.
If I see you die right next to the plane...
Oh, wait.
I guess I have more photos.
That's what I'm saying.
Dang it.
I got his ass, though.
I have one more.
Oh, wait.
That's Simba?
Wait, wait.
Do a pose.
Oh, wait.
Did she die?
Yes.
She was a little too cocky there.
Her helmet, though.
Well, I guess no helmet for her.
She's got three photos.
Alright.
Scram.
You die.
Oh, he's walking.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God.
I think you could have actually died there.
Oh, my God.
Literally, a car flew over your head when you...
I got killed because I decided to take a selfie as a bus flew at me.
Wait, did it show up?
Did that photo show up?
Oh, my God.
I hope so.
I want to see.
I hope we get that photo of the bus.
What the fuck is this photo?
I think that was the bus that flew at me.
What's this?
Very nice.
Nice.
Damn, we almost got it in one.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we just need one more.
Wait, how many photos do we need?
Like, 600.
600.
I like this photo the best.
The Darwin Award right there.
Let's download that.
I like how we have two POV of this.
You have me taking a photo of her.
We need more because you were in the picture.
Yeah, I was also in the photo.
Oh, my God.
It's so cursed.
Wait, which one was the photo we got hit?
I don't know.
Maybe it didn't go up before I fucking ate shit.
No.
This one is so stupid.
I like this one.
This one got the most points, though.
Because it was a repeated photo.
This is the second photo you took.
If this was your first photo, you would have got more.
Yeah, I think so.
I mean, that photo alone got you a thousand.
That's crazy.
Hell, yeah.
This game is easier, I think, than Lethal Company.
Much easier, yeah.
Because we know when to go, too, now.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Apocalyptic.
What?
That is so, like...
What does that mean?
The end of the world.
I guess explosions and monsters and corpses.
Yeah, but how is that worse than Darwin Awards?
Because you have to put yourself in danger for Darwin Awards.
Yeah, but, like...
Oh, do you want that flashlight?
Here you go.
Oh, thank you.
Sorry, I couldn't get your helmet because I had...
Yeah, no, no.
You're good.
We're so good, we don't die.
I can probably do, like, one more.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's finish this, guys.
As fellow journalists...
As long as someone gets out with, like, two photos, we win.
Yeah, we can... We don't have to be super risky here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, it's, uh... We can find the...
What was it?
The little doggies, right?
Guys, we're one day off of retirement, guys.
Oh, yeah, we're one day off of retirement.
Oh, and then we can, like, do...
If we pass this, we can do the later levels with Snuffy.
The final level.
Yeah, we'll save progress, I think.
Man, I sure can't wait to finish my job as a journalist and go spend the rest of my days with my family.
In and out super safe.
There'll be no problems.
There'll never be...
Not a single problem.
...better thing than to go retire in the Bahamas.
The Bahamas.
Do you wanna go to this building over here?
Let's go to that building.
Yeah.
It's closer to the jump skip, too.
True, true.
These rivals are always...
They're always really close, but I don't think they're actually anywhere.
The doki skip.
The basic fucking crouch jump art.
Aw, man, we're in this building again.
Oh, there's a trap here?
Yeah, but I invented it, though.
You invented crouch jumping?
That's crazy.
Yeah, but I invented it in this game.
Okay, okay.
But wait, before you do...
Okay, yeah, yeah, I'm ready.
Doki, take a pose in front.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
I'm dying, I'm dying.
You're fine, I got you.
Oh, shoot.
Careful, careful, careful!
Oh, you are so dead.
I'm alive.
I don't think Mint's alive.
Oh, you're good, you're good.
Oh, she's alive, too!
Oh, my God.
That was... Okay, we basically got the photo.
I got 733 points from that.
I gamed, I gamed!
I got 1,200 fucking points.
Alright, let's go, let's leave.
We did it, we did our job.
Yeah, we did it, we did it.
We did it.
I gamed, I gamed!
I got gamer of the year right there.
Holy shit.
That was pretty easy.
Watch out, watch out!
Tiny man, tiny man.
Oh no, not the doki skip.
He's in front of the doki skip.
He's guarding the doki skip, what a dick.
If I die, you have to get my camera.
This is a very, very...
I got the apocalypse scenario in it.
Oh, you got the apocalypse?
I got apocalypse, yeah.
Okay, let's see if I can make this.
I did it last time, first try.
I did it, I did it.
Nice.
Alright, it's time to go.
But what if we waited for the giant monster?
We could just wait up here, nothing gets us here.
Yeah, I guess.
Like, we already saw that monster.
Why don't we just wait by the helicopter?
Yeah, that's true, we can wait by it and exit it when he shows up.
But one of us has to stay outside.
You actually went into the helicopter?
Not me.
Okay, but if I die, get my camera.
Oh, there's a guy over there.
There he is, there's a little guy over there.
You heard that too, right?
He's coming over.
He is coming over.
He won't get us.
We might have to leave if he doesn't stop walking towards us.
He's like hobbling over towards us.
Oh, he doesn't see you, he's blind.
He's nearsighted.
Why can I hear like ambient Jurassic Park noises?
Oh, you're right, I hear that too.
Because they're all around us, we're just...
Come on!
Hey!
Big guy!
There's no one behind us, so...
Oh my god.
It really is super Jurassic Park.
I feel like I'm in the Jurassic World park ride.
Here it comes!
There's the explosion!
Camera's ready!
Does the red light mean that's... Oh my fucking god!
Oh, you don't get points from doing that in the plane, I just noticed.
I just got an even better photo, 1300.
Oh, I got a 1201.
Yeah.
It was for taking shot of those explosions with you in the foreground.
Yeah, yeah, me too, I got that too.
The helicopter guy's so chill about this.
Just another day on the job.
I'm ready for Slenderman.
What?
I got bravery for standing far away from the photo.
Okay, I'll wave.
Number three.
Hello!
I'm gonna fist pump.
Oh, it's a different one!
Oh, it's a tornado.
It's a tornado.
Hmm, hello.
Can you strike a pose for me?
Thank you.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, okay.
Oh wow, you're trying to maximize it.
Oh, we already got it.
There we go.
I'm hoping that he explodes something, because it'll probably give us extra points.
That's true.
It is kind of right now.
Oh, there's a club there too.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming to the club.
Alright.
Toki is so bad.
He's already in the fucking helicopter.
You said he's coming, so I ran!
I heard the instructions clear as day.
Let's see what happens if he gets sucked into the tornado.
Give this journalist a medal of bravery.
Give me a purple heart right there.
Oh, what the heck?
That's why I'm the only survivor.
We all survived, what are you talking about?
Alright, let's see.
I'm pretty sure Lime got the best photo.
She got the 1300.
Yeah, Lime's award winning photo.
Yeah, the award winning photo right there.
Oh yeah, that one.
Mine was apparently just that much cooler.
I can't believe I...
Oh, that was cool.
That one was cool.
Oh, I look awesome!
Mine's got fire in it though, so...
Yeah, better photo.
We did it!
Yay!
Alright, guys.
Look at my headliner here.
That's actually a really cool photo though.
It is actually.
It's not a fucking selfie, no one is.
So our photos went...
Mint doing something real sus with a monster.
An actually cool photo.
Monster clutch.
Selfie.
Actually cool photo.
This actually looks like something I can see in a newspaper.
It actually has some form of composition going on.
Oh yeah, how do I save this shit?
I can submit this at the start of my journalism career.
Oh, here we go.
Rule of thirds, baby!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
We did it.
We learned how to be real journalists.
Yay!
I can't wait to show Snuffy when she gets a new CPU.
Oh yeah, we'll continue our run and get to level 5 with Snuffy.
Hell yeah.
That's the trial by fucking fire.
It's like, hey Snuffy, go into this building and she gets mogged by a headcrab or something.
We're like one last...
We all come back for one last heist.
As reporters.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, there's you hanging.
Jesus Christ.
Oh wow.
There's me dancing next to it too.
I'll be like, yeah.
You're not even like...
What is this photo?
You're not even in that photo.
You look like you're not a journalist.
You're like actually going at the paparazzi.
Oh, you're right.
It's like, no photos!
No photos!
Yeah.
It's like when Jake Paul goes to the forest.
Protecting Mint's privacy.
Oh my god.
What's this?
Oh yeah.
Oh, this is where we did the explosions.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's the guy that comes out.
It's the guy.
I saw him in there.
Me taking a selfie.
Yeah.
Wow.
GGs, guys.
It was a great pleasure being journalists with all of you.
Yeah, I had a great time.
We should have a selfie.
How did this photo not get a bigger score?
Look at that shit.
Let's get a selfie together.
One last photo.
Oh yeah, okay, okay.
Oh, one last selfie.
We should all do a selfie together.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Wait, how does this work?
How do we get together?
Crouch.
Oh, there we go, there we go.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh wait, no, not like that.
Oh shit.
I'm trying to A, I'm trying to A.
Oh, I'm trying to A too.
One last photo for the ride.
It's beautiful.
I love that you guys still have your safety helmets on.
Yeah, we're special.
Hell yeah.
GG's everyone.
Thanks for playing Headliners.
It was a lot of fun.
Let's hope we can get Snuffy in next time.
Hell yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's hope Snuffy's PC...
Yeah, I feel better, both of you.
Yeah, I'm gonna rest my voice right after this, but GG's guys, GG's.
Let's hope Snuffy's PC will be okay.
I know.
Alright, bye bye.
Bye bye.
Bye.
Oh, oh.
Alright, bye to you too.
Bye.
Alright, guys.
Look at that.
We did it.
I love that.
Oh, I'm in Disconnect.
That's to show you guys my Headliners.
But, yeah, that was a fun game.
I'm sorry I can't talk for too long because my voice has made it to its final end.
Tomorrow's sponsor is Nikkei.
We are going to be looking into the Evangelion collaboration that's launching today slash tomorrow.
So that is our sponsor for tomorrow.
Everything's finalized, so I can announce it now.
But I'm gonna rest my voice now.
My voice is dead.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'm gonna rest now.
I'll see you guys.
Bye, everyone.
Bye.
I hate doing that off the head, but I legitimately can't talk anymore.
Alright, everybody.
Bye.